je suis heureuse de souhaiter en votre
nom la bienvenue à Monsieur Anatole
Collinet Makosso Premier ministre de la
République du Congo
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup
l'ordre du jour appelle la séance de
questions au gouvernement
[Musique]
s'il vous plaît la première question va
être posée par la présidente Chatelain
pour le Cope écologique
merci madame la Présidente chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à la
première ministre chef de gouvernement
et depuis quelques jours juste
constitutionnel et présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale le 17 mai en lieu
et place du Conseil constitutionnel vous
jugiez un constitutionnel la proposition
de loi de l'abrogation de la réforme des
retraites le 23 mai vous convient qui
est la présence de l'Assemblée nationale
a un petit déjeuner pour lui un semer
l'or d'abandonner son rôle de présidente
et de s'aligner sur la position du
gouvernement les conséquences de ce
petit déjeuner nous les subissons
aujourd'hui madame brande Pivet qui
avait alors jusqu'à leur refusé
d'outrepasser le règlement de cette
assemblée et le rôle que lui confère
qu'il confère au président de la
commission des finances a depuis fait
volte-face au détriment de la dépendance
de nos institutions
je tiens d'ailleurs à saluer le travail
remarquable des ricoquerel qui se tient
debout malgré la pression et qui défend
envers et contre vous la tradition
républicaine de cette assemblée
ma question est donc la suivante dans
une démocratie chahutée par votre
gouvernement ou la séparation des
pouvoirs est un principe fondamental de
notre République jusqu'où êtes-vous prêt
à aller dans le dévoiement de nos
institutions pour ne pas perdre la face
je vous remercie
la parole est à madame la Première
ministre merci madame la Présidente
mesdames et messieurs les députés madame
la Présidente Cyrielle châtelain il y a
la vérité sur nos retraites et notre
réforme un déséquilibre qui menace c'est
l'avenir de notre système par
répartition et une réforme qui rétablit
l'équilibre à horizon 2030 en tenant
compte de la situation de chacun puisque
quatre Français sur 10 pourront partir
avant 64 ans
madame la Présidente il y a aussi la
réalité des faits sur la manière dont ce
texte a été construit et adopté des mois
de concertation avec les partenaires
sociaux
175 heures de débat parlementaire et des
décisions très claires du Conseil
constitutionnel qui ont validé
l'essentiel du texte et rejeter deux
propositions de référendum d'initiative
partagée pour la projet
madame la Présidente il y a enfin la
réalité sur votre attitude et celle de
vos alliés de la nupes
décrit des injures de l'obstruction pour
empêcher l'examen du texte et je vous
rappelle que c'est Jean-Luc Mélenchon
lui-même qui avait intimé l'ordre sur
Twitter à la nupasse de ne pas débattre
et de ne pas voter le report de l'âge
de ne pas débattre de cet article madame
la Présidente alors après des semaines
d'antis parlementarisme nous aboutissons
logiquement à des manœuvres
anticonstitutionnels la proposition de
loi que vous évoquez aggraverait
lourdement les charges publiques
réduirait les recettes et méconnaient
donc frontalement l'article 40 de notre
Constitution madame la Présidente
Chatelain on ne défend pas les
institutions à coups de propositions de
loi anticonstitutionnelles on ne ment
pas aux Français en portant avec la plus
grande démagogie un texte dont chacun
sait ici pertinemment qu'il serait
censuré par le Conseil constitutionnel
s'y parvenait au bout de son cheminement
parlementaire alors madame la Présidente
jusqu'au bout nous défendrons la réalité
face à la démagogie et laquelle la
Constitution face à ceux qui la
remettent en cause je vous remercie
beaucoup madame la Première ministre
madame la Présidente
[Applaudissements]
madame la Première ministre l'insuline
dans cette hémicycle c'est vous quand
depuis des mois vous montez accroché à
vos vis les grands discours ça suffit
notre démocratie est fragile ce n'est
pas un acquis c'est quelque chose pour
laquelle on doit se battre chaque jour
le dévoiement que vous faites jour après
jour de son fonctionnement est
extrêmement dangereux je vous le dis
madame la Première ministre soyez sport
le 8 juin acceptez votre défaite
je vous remercie
je vous remercie la parole est à
monsieur le président Olivier Marleix
pour le groupe les républicains
la précédente madame la Première
ministre tous les indicateurs le
montrent le logement est en crise 100
000 logements construits de moins qu'il
y a 15 ans chute de 30% sur un an du
nombre de maisons individuelles vendues
explosion des faillites de promoteurs de
constructeur individuel d'agents
immobilières plus 83% ce sont
aujourd'hui 150
000 emplois qui sont menacés dans cette
filière les causes de cette crise elles
sont malheureusement totalement
identifiées d'abord évidemment la hausse
des prix de construction à cause de la
guerre en Ukraine le renchérissement des
projets à cause des normes le manque de
fonciers disponible à cause de la
politique du Zéro artificialisation et
puis évidemment la hausse des taux
d'intérêt aujourd'hui les Français ne
trouvent emprunter autour de 4,5% sur 20
ans ce qui exclut de plus plus de nos
compatriotes dans leur projet d'achat
puisqu'ils se voient opposés des refus
de prêt par les banques madame la
Première ministre on sait depuis 2017
que le logement n'intéresse pas beaucoup
le président de la République qui a fait
sienne cette idéologie selon laquelle on
construitait trop en France et qu'il
faudrait que les Français renoncent à
leurs rêves de la maison
individuelle pardon mais cette fois la
crise est la pénurie de logement
destruction d'emplois baisse du poids
d'achat allez vous répondre madame la
Première ministre au cri d'alarme que
vous ont adressé les professionnels de
cette filière
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à madame la Première
ministre merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le président Olivier Marleix
tout d'abord nous partageons le constat
l'offre de logement est insuffisante ou
inadaptée dans certains territoires elle
peut bloquer nos compatriotes dans leur
projet de mobilité elle peut être un
frein à l'emploi particulièrement dans
les zones en forte tension comme les
métropoles cette situation résulte de
d'enjeux structurels dont les causes
sont multiples je pense notamment à la
baisse du nombre de permis de construire
des livrets ou encore à la hausse des
prix du foncier à cela s'ajoutent des
difficultés conjoncturelles avec la
hausse rapide des taux d'intérêt qui
freinent la demande de logement les
transactions immobilières dans l'ancien
et grippe l'accès au marché locatif
alors nous sommes bien conscients des
difficultés actuelles et le gouvernement
est pleinement mobilisé pour agir avec
tous les acteurs concernés nous avons
déjà annoncé des premières mesures pour
répondre à ces difficultés en regardant
comment assouplir certaines règles
d'accès au crédit immobilier ou encore
par le rachat de 17000 logements par la
Caisse des dépôts des consignations nous
devons aussi agir pour relever le défi
de la transition écologique notamment
par une politique ambitieuse de
rénovation énergétique que nous avons
lancé dans le précédent quinquennat et
monsieur le président Olivier marlex
avec tous les acteurs avec les élus
locaux nous voulons aller bien plus loin
des mesures complémentaires seront
présentées lors du Conseil national de
la refondation consacrée au logement qui
se réunira la semaine prochaine qui a
mobilisé de nombreux acteurs tous les
acteurs impliqués sur ces enjeux j'y
participerai personnellement et donc ce
sera l'occasion d'apporter des réponses
mais je vous confirme monsieur le
Président marlax que nous sommes à
l'écoute de toutes les propositions
toutes les bonnes propositions sur ces
sujets je vous remercie je vous remercie
madame la Première ministre monsieur le
président
je ne suis pas sûr écouter votre réponse
que vous soyez totalement consciente de
l'urgence de la crise si vous n'avez pas
de solution permettait que les députés
des républicains vous en proposent une
fois de plus d'abord libérer du foncier
c'est l'urgence il faut assouplir les
règles et puis faciliter le recours des
Français à l'emprunt en élargissant le
prêt à taux zéro ou en rétablissant la
déduction des intérêts d'emprunt comme
le puzzle à droite lorsqu'elle était au
pouvoir merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
monsieur le président
la parole est à Madame Laure La Valette
pour le rassemblement national
merci madame la présidente Madame la
Premier ministre le président a donc
menti dimanche 21 mai dans un
documentaire diffusé sur le service
public le ministre de la Justice ici
présent à assumé au grand jour votre
incapacité exécuter les obligations de
quitter le territoire prononcé à l'égard
de centaines de milliers de gens entrés
illégalement en France ou condamné
depuis le président a donc menti quand
il annoncé en 2019 que 100% des occultés
F serait exécutés depuis les chiffres
déjà embarrassants sont devenus
ridicules et moins de 10% des décisions
sont appliquées alors cette énième
promesse de gascon lancée par vantardise
d'un chef de l'état conscient qu'elle ne
sera pas tenue abîme un peu plus la
confiance entre le politique et un
peuple qui n'est plus préservé qui n'est
plus protégé
fiasco de l'océan Viking humiliation de
votre tournée au Maghreb silence
coupable face aux provocations des
Comores c'est tout le pays qui de Menton
à Calais Plou sous le joug de votre
inaction le président a donc menti vous
êtes tous impuissant l'impuissance et le
symptôme de la résignation vous vous
résignez et plongez le pays dans un
marasme migratoire devenu insupportable
pour plus de 80% des Français qui
déplorent votre échec alors ma question
madame borne est la suivante comme chef
de ce gouvernement qui décidez-vous de
dédire le garde des sceaux ou le
président de la République je vous
remercie
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier Véran
ministre délégué chargé du renouveau
démocratique
porte-parole du gouvernement
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
lors de la Valette j'excuse l'absence
j'excuse d'abord l'absence du ministre
de l'intérieur des chargée des Outre-mer
qui est actuellement en déplacement
officiel en Nouvelle-Calédonie même la
Valette avant de vous répondre
factuellement et par des chiffres
je ne partage pas votre assertion selon
laquelle la France serait un pays qui
plie la France ne plie pas sur le jeu de
quoi que ce soit la France est un pays
qui est fort et l'instrument c'est un
pays qui défend sa place dans l'Europe
et à l'international quand on dit comme
vous le dites madame la députée aimer
son pays on ne dit pas dans l'enceinte
de l'Assemblée nationale que la France
plie ou que la France craque jamais
ensuite vous interrogez le gouvernement
sur la politique française en matière de
respect des obligations de quitter le
territoire français je veux répondre
madame la député il y a une dynamique
qui a été créée en 2017 il y a eu
d'ailleurs il y a d'ailleurs une loi qui
a été adoptée par cette majorité
présidentielle qui a permis d'avoir des
résultats comment d'abord en augmentant
la durée maximale de rétention à 90
jours ensuite en passant à 24 heures la
durée potentielle de rétention d'un
étranger pour pouvoir vérifier le droit
au séjour et les résultats ils étaient
là madame la députée puisque entre 2017
et 2019 le nombre d'expulsions a
augmenté sensiblement dans notre pays
ensuite il y a eu ensuite il y a eu la
période du covid où le monde entier et
l'Europe notamment a connu évidemment
des perturbations en matière de respect
des amputés F c'était le cas chez tous
les voisins vous pouvez pas le nier ses
factuels et ensuite que s'est-il passé
ensuite il y a eu une applique d'abord
une instruction du ministre de
l'Intérieur qui a permis de placer un
centre de rétention administrative en
priorité les personnes étrangères qui
ont été victimes qui ont été
responsables de délits et tout cela nous
a permis d'avoir des chiffres tangibles
d'abord 850 étrangers connus pour des
faits de radicalisation ont été éloignés
depuis 2017
3615 étrangers ont été auteurs de
troubles à l'ordre public ont été
éloignés en 2022 c'est une augmentation
qui était quasiment en double par
rapport à 2021 ce sont des résultats
mesdames la député et nous en aurons
d'autres puisque vous le savez nous
avons entamé avec les oppositions avec
cette majorité des discussions en vue de
faire évoluer notre droit en matière de
l'immigration d'intégration merci
beaucoup Madame La Valette
merci Madame la président monsieur le
ministre rien égale votre mauvaise foi
sinon votre bilan catastrophique les
Français ont des yeux pour voir vous ne
répondez à rien vous n'assumez rien et
vous ne faites rien figurez-vous que le
RN est prêt à agir et notre projet est
tellement solide qu'il en vient même à
inspirer nos collègues LR qui ne se
gênent pas pour le copier
même si même si comme des mauvais
copieurs ils oublient la priorité
nationale mais enfin bon voilà alors
figurez-vous que le rassemblement
national est prêt à rendre au français
le contrôle à leur rendre leur
souveraineté avant de le pouvoir et ce
que vous ne faites pas Marine Le Pen le
fera dans 4 ans
merci beaucoup
la parole est à Monsieur
Frédéric descrosa et pour le groupe
Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente avec votre
permission avant de poser ma question je
voudrais rendre un hommage à Frédéric
Leclerc imoff décédé il y a exactement
un an en Ukraine dans le cadre de
l'exercice de son métier de journaliste
ce drame nous rappelle
la portée irremplaçable de ce métier
pour la démocratie parce qu'il n'est pas
de liberté de décider d'agir sans
liberté de savoir et de connaître et
cette mission est remplie au risque de
leur vie par les femmes et les hommes
qui le conduisent notamment dans les
cadres conflictuels comme celui de
l'Ukraine ma question s'adresse à la
première ministre et elle porte sur le
rapport de la Cour des comptes qui est
sorti récemment et qui recommande au
pouvoir public d'adopter une stratégie
de réduction de notre cheptel en France
outre l'incongruité de magistrats dont
on découvre qu'ils auraient des
compétences d'agriculteurs ou d'agronome
et qui ne font aucune distinction entre
les différentes catégories d'élevage et
de cheptel je note que dans cette
recommandation il n'est tenu aucun
compte de l'impact sur l'importation de
viande qui se retirent à tout point de
vue de celle que nous produisons en
France et qui ne tient aucun compte non
plus des effets de bord sur le lait on
continue de vivre dans un pays qui croit
qu'il aura toujours du lait et des
fromages sans viande sur la polyculture
élevage vers lequel devrait conduire
notre transition agroécologique et sur
la valorisation d'espace notamment de
moyenne montagne de montagnes sur
lesquelles il n'existe aujourd'hui
aucune alternative donc nous allons tout
droit vers une espèce d'épisodes à la
Black Mirror ou les riches pourraient
accéder à poire merlan araignée surprise
royale de bêtes nourielle élevage et les
pauvres manger de la viande cellulaire
peut-être un jour produit de par des
imprimantes alimentaires en
libre-service dans des supermarchés donc
ma question madame la Première ministre
c'est qu'avez-vous à dire aux éleveurs
dans le cadre d'attaque incessantes sur
leur métier et quelle est la doctrine du
gouvernement en matière de concours des
pouvoirs publics à l'investissement dans
l'innovation et la recherche sur les
protéines alimentaires et la transition
agro-écologique des élevages
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Frédéric descrosailles
je suis élu de Normandie je connais
l'importance de l'élevage bovin pour nos
territoires comme pour notre économie je
connais l'engagement des éleveurs et
leur inquiétude en particulier après le
rapport de la Cour des comptes la
semaine dernière
nous avons un modèle d'élevage bovin
dont nous pouvons être fiers un modèle
d'élevage dont je veux affirmer qu'il a
un avenir dans notre pays
c'est pour cela que le gouvernement
apporte un soutien sans faille à nos
éleveurs en faisant la transparence sur
l'évolution des prix de l'alimentation
animale à travers la PAC ou l'élevage et
la filière la plus soutenue ou encore
dans les négociations commerciales en
nous opposant à l'accord entre l'Union
européenne et le Mercosur comme la
rappeler le président de la République
lors du Salon de l'Agriculture
je n'oublie pas non plus que l'élevage
peut avoir des effets bénéfiques pour
notre environnement chaque année les
prairies stockent 8 millions de tonnes
de CO2 et l'élevage permet la
construction d'un réseau de haies et
d'infrastructures agroécologiques utiles
notamment pour les sols pour autant les
défis devant nous sont majeurs nous
devons baisser nos émissions de gaz à
effet de serre mener notre transition
agricole et accompagner la structuration
des filières et vous le savez monsieur
le député vous qui suivez le travail que
nous menons sur les plans de filière
depuis 2017 alors disons-le clairement
oui l'élevage bovin devra prendre toute
sa part dans la transition agricole il y
est prêt il s'y engage déjà oui le
secteur de l'élevage bovin devra évoluer
pour retrouver un modèle économique
solide et durable mais non il ne sera
pas la variable d'ajustement et pour
être réussie la transition écologique et
agricole doit se faire avec les Français
avec les éleveurs et non pas contre eux
aussi je veux donner aux éleveurs de la
visibilité sur les défis devant nous et
bâtir avec eux un avenir soutenable
économiquement et environnementalement
je compte sur eux pour s'engager
pleinement dans ce travail c'est le sens
de la planification écologique que nous
menons avec le ministre de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires ça vous dérange que je
réponde à la question de votre madame la
députée
[Applaudissements]
madame chiquiro s'il vous plaît vous
n'avez pas la parole
[Applaudissements]
mais oui vous n'avez pas la parole
madame la Première ministre nous vous
écoutons
écologique que nous menons avec le
ministre de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires
Christophe Béchu et le ministre de la de
l'agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire Marc fenault et d'où nous
présenterons la stratégie complète en
juin je vous remercie merci beaucoup
madame la Première ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Charles de
Courson pour le groupe yote
[Musique]
ma question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre madame la Première
ministre
le gros plus haute a déposé dans son
créneau une proposition de loi visant à
l'abrogation du recul de l'âge de départ
à la retraite et à la création d'une
conférence de financement du système de
retraite
cette proposition de loi a été déclaré
recevable par le Bureau de l'Assemblée
nationale et a été inscrite le 8 juin à
l'ordre du jour de notre assemblée
ce matin
le président de la commission des
finances saisie par la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales là
également déclaré recevable
cette proposition de loi vise un double
objectif permettre enfin à l'Assemblée
nationale de se prononcer sur la hausse
de deux années de l'âge légal de départ
à la retraite
et deuxièmement de lancer une conférence
de financement du système de retraite
pour aboutir à des propositions
équilibrées socialement et
financièrement elle pourrait être
intégrée dès 2024 dans la prochaine loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
certaines rumeurs madame la Première
ministre selon lesquels le gouvernement
pourrait être avoir recours au vote
bloqué de l'article 44 3 de la
Constitution d'autres rumeurs évoquent
une éventuelle nouvelle réunion du
bureau de l'Assemblée nationale pour
écarter cette proposition il y a encore
d'autres rumeurs aussi ma question est
toute simple
le gouvernement laissera-t-il
l'Assemblée nationale se prononçait sur
cette proposition de loi ou aura-t-il de
nouveau recours à des dispositions
visant à en empêcher le vote
je vous remercie
[Musique]
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier du top ministre du
Travail de l'insertion et du plein
emploi merci madame la Présidente
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député de Courson comme vous
l'avez dit Monsieur le Député vous avez
déposé une proposition de loi et pour ce
qui concerne les questions relatives à
la recevabilité des propositions de loi
au nom de la séparation en application
du principe de séparation des pouvoirs
le gouvernement n'a pas à se prononcer
sur les procédures propres à l'Assemblée
nationale
ceci étant ceci étant monsieur le député
vous qui depuis maintenant plusieurs
décennies bataillées sur les projets de
loi de finances vous savez pertinemment
qu'en proposant une charge de 15
milliards d'euros supplément votre
proposition nous paraît-il recevable et
nous paraît aussi un constitutionnel
comme l'a dit madame la Première
ministre monsieur le député de Courson
votre proposition loi dégraderait les
comptes publics de 15 milliards d'euros
comment allez-vous le financer allez
vous augmenter les cotisations de 1000
euros par an sur tous les Français
allez-vous diminuer les pensions de
retraite allez-vous sabrer dans les
budgets de l'éducation nationale de la
transition écologique ou de la sécurité
comment monsieur de Courson allez-vous
financer ces 15 milliards il y a une
chose de sûr il a mis une seule réalité
c'est que vous ne pourrez plus jamais
monsieur le député venir dans cette
hémic cycle et doctement faire la leçon
sur les finances publiques aujourd'hui
avec votre proposition de loi si
d'aventure elle était adoptée vous
mettez un mâle et vous mettez en danger
le système de répartition vous dégradez
les finances publiques et vous tournez
le dos à tout esprit de responsabilité
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
monsieur de Courson
je regrette que ce ne soit pas la
première ministre en personne qui est
qui est répandue à cette question
et je voudrais
et je voudrais au surplus dire à
Monsieur dufe que cette proposition de
loi dégrade les comptes publics de 270
millions en 2023 et que la conférence
sociale il y a des gens responsables
parmi les partenaires sociaux votre
temps de parole je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre
attendez 2 secondes monsieur le ministre
avant de vous exprimer que l'on puisse
vous écouter allez-y merci à madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Député de Courson
comment vous sentez-vous comment vous
sentez-vous car le Front National et les
filles se lève pour me soutenir dans une
admirable de Na identitaire et
extrémiste
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Madame Sarah le grain
pour le beau plat français soumise
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît mes chers collègues un
peu de silence madame Legrand la parole
ben vous ne voulez pas écouter votre
collègue madame Legrand vous avez la
parole
présidente collègue ministre samedi
dernier Justine Triet a remporté la
Palme d'Or au Festival de Cannes
[Applaudissements]
français la troisième par une femme
comme le prix Nobel Danie Arnaud cette
palme fait la fierté de la France
il y aurait de quoi l'applaudir il y
aurait de quoi l'applaudir ici même si
Emmanuel Macron n'a toujours pas jugé
bon de la saluer il a bien félicité
Erdogan pour sa réélection mais il faut
dire car Dogan lui ne critique pas la
répression autoritaire de ce monarque
présidentiel
gouvernant contre son peuple pour lui
voler deux ans de vie madame la ministre
de la Culture en vous disant estomaquer
par son discours vous avez donné le
signal faites la terre et j'ai été
estomac et moi devant ses meutes de
militants macronistes et
d'éditorialistes fustigeant son
ingratitude estomacée devant leur
ignorance crasse du financement du
cinéma devant leur vision réactionnaire
de l'artiste entre un museur de foire et
valait du pouvoir alors dites-moi ce qui
vous distingue ici de l'extrême droite
et de Bolloré alors oui oui madame la
ministre Justine Trief et plus pour
l'exception culturelle française que
vous elle veut vibrer les origines
résistantes de notre festival de Cannes
qui n'avait pas vocation à devenir ce
tapis rouge bunkérisé sous au bruit des
casseroles et aux cris des féministes
elle a l'alerte lancée par de nombreux
artistes et professionnels sur les
logiques de marchandisation et de
concentration qui menace l'indépendance
et la diversité du cinéma français
défendre l'exception culturelle ce n'est
pas nommé le libéral Dominique Boutonnat
à la tête du CNC instance
protectionniste et redistributif créé en
46 ce n'est pas non plus utilisé le Pass
Culture pour gaver de fonds publics la
boîte de conseils d'Eric Garandeau
ex-président du CNC passé chez Tik Tok
voici ce que vous dit Nicolas Mathieu la
main qui nourrit les artistes n'est pas
la vôtre vous n'êtes pas nos patrons
mais les serviteurs du bien public vous
n'avez rien à dire des libertés qui nous
appartiennent parmi laquelle la liberté
de nous exprimer de vous critiquer je
vous dis merci ma chère collègue la
parole est à Madame rémab de Malak
ministre de la Culture
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Legrand premièrement je tiens à
féliciter Justine trie et ses
producteurs pour cette palme d'or dont
on est très fier
la dixième pour la France la troisième
pour une femme ce n'est pas rien
deuxièmement je n'ai jamais contesté le
principe de sa déclaration les artistes
sont libres de s'exprimer partout où ils
veulent quand ils veulent c'est un
principe intangible de notre démocratie
la liberté d'expression et je le
défendrai toujours
ensuite ce que je demande c'est pas du
tout de la gratitude c'est juste de
l'honnêteté intellectuelle et à vous
aussi
de l'honnêteté intellectuelle à quel
fait quel chiffre donnez-moi des faits
des chiffres qui prouveraient que ce
président féministe depuis 2017 ont
détruit l'exception culturelle où on
crée une marchandisation de la culture
c'est tout le contraire nous n'avons
fait que renforcer ce modèle dont nous
sont fiers et qui existe depuis 1946
vous l'avez rappelé avec la création du
CNC mais qu'est-ce que nous avons fait
nous avons créé de nouvelles taxes pour
faire entrer de nouveaux de nouvelles
ressources dans le budget du CNC la taxe
sur les plateformes qu'est-ce que nous
avons fait nous avons porté au niveau
européen la directive droit d'auteur la
directive SMA qui a obligé les
plateformes aussi à financer à hauteur
de 20% de leur chiffre d'affaires la
création française et européenne c'est
cette majorité qui a défendu cette
exception culturelle haut et fort elle
est bien vivante et c'est la preuve avec
cette palme d'or qu'elle est bien
vivante pendant la crise nous avons
déployé plus de 4 00 millions d'euros
d'aide exceptionnelle au cinéma nous
avons préservé l'intermittence du
spectacle et vous avez mentionné le Pass
Culture c'est très intéressant justement
avec le Pass Culture 4 millions et demi
de places de cinéma ont été financés par
l'État par l'État pour aider les jeunes
à aller au cinéma et créer du désir de
cinéma dans notre pays voilà l'exception
culturelle madame la députée je vous
remercie madame la ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Thomas ménager
pour le groupe rassemblement national
merci Madame présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'économie et des finances il y a
quelques jours le président de la
République déclaré je cite la France
réindustrialise une fois encore se déni
du réel nous inquiète tous les chiffres
montrent que derrière la communication
politique notre industrie est
considérablement affaibli depuis
l'élection d'Emmanuel Macron en 6 ans la
production a baissé de 4,45% en volume
tandis que la part de l'industrie
manufacturière a perdu un point dans la
valeur ajoutée globale pour tenter de
réindustrialiser le pays vous enchaînez
les plans sans aucun résultat plan
France relance plan France 2030 au
commissariat aux plans malheureusement
dans nos territoires les seuls plans que
nous connaissons ce sont les plans
sociaux dans ma circonscription à
Châlette-sur-Loing dans le Loiret une
nouvelle vague de suppression de postes
menaces l'usine Hutchinson filiale de
Total énergie après 120 emplois
supprimés en 2020 ce sont désormais 170
emplois supplémentaires qui sont menacés
malheureusement monsieur le ministre
vous n'avez toujours pas compris que des
industrialisations riment avec
délocalisation la semaine dernière
madame la Première ministre lors de la
présentation du plan visant à limiter
nos émissions de gaz à effet de serre
vous n'avez rien proposé pour s'attaquer
à la principale source de nos émissions
les importations avec Marine Le Pen nous
avons des solutions pour
réindustrialiser le pays et répondre aux
différents enjeux qu'ils soient
environnementaux économique ou sociaux
votre politique ne peut se contenter
d'une stratégie de démarchage des
investisseurs étrangers qui conduit bien
trop souvent au dépeçage de nos fleurons
et à l'absence de création d'emploi
pendant que vous vous réjouissiez de
l'arrivée d'investisseurs chinois ou
taïwanais un des plus puissants groupes
français démantèle progressivement une
de ses filiales industrielles aussi
Monsieur le Ministre au-delà de vos
grandes déclarations que comptez-vous
faire concrètement pour sauvegarder les
170 postes menacés à l'usine Hutchinson
à Châlette-sur-Loing et assuré surtout
la pérennité de ce site je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Bruno Le Maire
ministre de l'Économie des Finances de
la souveraineté industrielle et
numérique oui madame le Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le députés ménager vous vous
indignez mais l'indignation n'a jamais
créé un seul emploi notre politique
industrielle si nous avec la majorité
avec un premier ministre avec le
président de la République pendant que
vous discutez j'attends toujours les
propositions du rassemblement national
sur l'industrie nous avons ouvert 300
usines supplémentaires depuis deux ans
nous avons créé 90000 emplois
industriels n'étaient pas arrivés depuis
deux décennies nous avons engagé la
réindustrialisation de la France nous
avons obtenu que l'Union européenne
change radicalement de politique pour
que nous puissions apporter des aides
d'État des crédits d'impôts des
subventions au développement de notre
industrie comme le faisait la Chine et
comme le faisait les États-Unis nous
avons décidé de réserver le bénéfice du
bonus électrique au seul véhicule
électrique qui respecteraient les normes
environnementales les plus strictes
c'est-à-dire ce produit sur notre
territoire nous avons ce matin inauguré
la première
usine de batterie électrique en France
et en Europe nous allons créer quatre
giga Factory 10 000 en points
industriels et vous appelez ça du vent
le vent c'est vos discours notre
politique ce sont des résultats
quant à votre territoire nous avons avec
le ministre de l'Industrie Roland
Lescure sauvé l'usine Duralex vous étiez
bien content que le gouvernement Vienne
protéger les emplois sauver votre
industrie sur votre territoire nous
n'avons jamais laissé tomber aucune
usine aucun ouvrier aucun de site
industriel et nous continuerons parce
que notre politique industrielle donne
des résultats
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
monsieur le député
monsieur le ministre et par rapport au
170 postes pour Hutchinson qu'est-ce que
il y a comme réponse est-ce que vous
pouvez nous apporter des réponses parce
que la seule réponse qu'il y a chaque
fois c'est Pôle Emploi malheureusement
pour ces salariés
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Jérémy
patrietus pour le groupe horizon merci
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la ministre délégué chargé des petites
et moyennes entreprises du commerce de
l'artisanat et du tourisme céramiste
dentellier plus Massier diamantaire et
bénisse orfèvre et mayor sur la fresque
maltier tisserand relieure ou encore
d'horreur les seuls noms de ces métiers
d'art suffisent à exprimer la beauté
l'excellence de ces savoir-faire ou la
finesse du geste tue la noblesse des
matériaux ces métiers sont de véritables
vocations puisque comme le disait
Stendhal la vocation c'est avoir pour
métier sa passion notre pays peut
s'enorgueillir de ses 281 métiers d'art
des savoir-faire d'exception que le
monde nous envie témoins de l'alchimie
entre tradition et innovation alliage
précieux de technologie moderne et de
savoir-faire ancestraux
héritier des manufactures créées par
Colbert et Louis XIV ces métiers d'art
font la fierté de notre pays contribuent
au rayonnement de la France dans le
monde à la vitalité de notre territoire
et notamment ruraux
qui rebâtirait la cathédrale Notre-Dame
de Paris sont les charpentiers les
tailleurs de pierre ou encore les
facteurs d'orgue et l'ensemble des
restaurateurs que serait les jardins de
Versailles sans les fontainiers ou les
sculpteurs sur pierre que serait la mode
sans boutonnier Brodeur chapelier
maudice ces hommes et ces femmes sont
les gardiens passionnés et ardents d'une
intelligence de la main qu'il nous faut
préserver les héritiers d'un patrimoine
immatériel d'une valeur inestimable
qu'il nous faut transmettre pourtant
aucun plan national d'envergure la
vérité jusqu'à ce jour dédié à ces
métiers d'art madame la ministre je
souhaite donc saluer avec force la
stratégie nationale ambitieuse de
soutien aux métiers d'art que vous
portez avec la ministre de la Culture et
que vous avez annoncé ce matin
pouvez-vous donc nous détailler votre
plan de 340 millions d'euros et
notamment la manière dont ils veulent se
décliner dans les territoires
pouvez-vous nous donner quelques mesures
phares des cinq axes de votre stratégie
pouvez-vous enfin nous expliquer comment
vous allez donner envie à ces jeunes de
se former à ces métiers passionnants ces
métiers de la main ces métiers de demain
je vous remercie merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue la parole est à Madame Olivia
Grégoire ministre délégué chargé des PME
du Commerce de l'Artisanat et du
Tourisme
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Député
Patrier laitue c'est effectivement nous
avons ce matin avec la ministre de la
Culture Rima Abdou Malak présenté notre
stratégie nationale en faveur des
métiers d'art les métiers d'art qui
semble-t-il n'intéresse pas tout le
monde dans cette émission mais les
métiers d'art ce sont 281 savoir-faire
séculaire les métiers d'art ce sont pas
moins de 60 000 entreprises notamment du
patrimoine vivant avec le label EPV les
métiers d'art ce sont 120000 artisans
d'art qui tous les jours transmettent et
font rayonner la France dans le monde
entier donc effectivement nous avons
après des mois d'échanges notamment avec
l'Institut National des Métiers d'Art le
Mobilier national à une facture de
Sèvres les CMA nous avons présenté ce
matin une stratégie nationale que je
suggère à certains d'écouter ne
serait-ce que par respect pour les
artisans d'art
par exemple un potentiel économique que
je viens de vous rappeler c'est 19
milliards d'euros dont 8 milliards
d'euros à l'export les métiers d'art les
métiers d'art se sont aussi de multiples
emplois que l'intelligence artificielle
ne nous ravira pas pour ceux que ça
intéresse l'étude faite par les
créateurs de chat GPT à démontré que
parmi les 34 métiers qui ne pourront pas
être avalés par l'intelligence
artificielle 34 métiers dont les
artisans d'art que vous avez cités oui
nous allons créer un CFA dédié oui nous
allons financer plus massivement le
tourisme de savoir-faire pour ouvrir les
portes de ces entreprises du patrimoine
vivant et les ateliers des maîtres d'art
nous allons aussi renforcer
considérablement le label Entreprise du
Patrimoine Vivant un objectif avoir 2500
entreprises du patrimoine vivant dans
l'année qui vient et nous allons aussi
considérablement avec la ministre de la
Culture renforcer le financement à
l'export pour ses entreprises en un mot
toujours difficile de l'expliquer en
deux minutes mieux les reconnaître enfin
les aider à se connaître entre eux pour
répondre ensemble à des projets et enfin
les faire connaître notamment à nos plus
jeunes pour assurer la pérennité de ces
métiers il n'y a pas de hasard il n'y a
que des rendez-vous disait Paul Eluard
nous serons au rendez-vous des métiers
d'art merci beaucoup madame la ministre
la parole est à Madame Marie-Christine
Daloz pour le groupe les républicain
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues monsieur et le garde des
sceaux jeudi dernier les corps d'une
femme et de ses deux enfants ont été
retrouvés sans vie à leur domicile tu es
de multiples coups de couteau dans la
circonscription du président marlex
alors même que cette femme s'était
présentée la veille au commissariat de
police dans la matinée de lundi le
procureur de la République de Chartres a
annoncé la mise en détention provisoire
de l'ex-conjoint de la victime à cette
heure présumé coupable ce trip homicide
un homme déjà condamné à un an
d'emprisonnement en septembre 2021 pour
des faits de violence envers sa femme et
sa fille et qui étaient en période de
probation comment la plainte de son
épouse n'a-t-elle pas pu donner l'alerte
les hommages se sont multipliés durant
tout le week-end mais aujourd'hui les
mots ne suffisent plus 36 féminicides
par conjoint ou ex conjoint ont été
dénombrés depuis le début de l'année en
France contre 24 à la même époque l'an
passé les chiffres s'aggravent sans que
nous soyons en capacité d'inverser la
tendance alors même que le président
Macron en avait fait une grande cause du
quinquennat en 2017 ce drame sordide a
décimé une famille et pose la question
récurrente de la protection des femmes
victimes de violence et de l'efficacité
des politiques publiques mises en place
aujourd'hui le dernier rapport du Haut
Conseil de l'égalité en janvier dernier
soulignait l'insuffisance de l'action
des pouvoirs publics en la matière
monsieur le ministre l'histoire se
répète dramatiquement
les effets d'annonce ne suffisent plus
écouter ces femmes et mettez en place un
véritable arsenal juridique capable de
leur offrir la protection que notre
République leur doit combien de victimes
devrons-nous encore déploé déplorés pour
que l'action soit efficace
merci beaucoup ma chère collègue la
parole est à me tuer Eric Dupond-Moretti
garde des sceaux ministre de la justice
madame la députée
la veille de ce que j'en sais concerne
en réalité un cambriolage
je souhaite que il n'y ait pas
d'amalgame sur sur ces questions parce
que entre un cambriolage dénoncé et des
violences avérées il y a un certain
nombre de nuances qui ne peuvent ici
échapper à personne pour le reste je
voudrais vous dire que nous avons
considérablement progresser dans les
mesures de protection qui ont été prises
et pardon de vous livrez quelques
chiffres évidemment ils sont aussi
dérisoires que les mots fassent à de
tels drames mais en 2019 madame la
députée c'est
300 téléphones graves dangers déployés
nous en sommes aujourd'hui à 3500
2455 interventions des forces de
sécurité intérieure c'est-à-dire
2455 drames éviter
1020 bracelets anti rapprochement
actuellement actif
3634 interventions des services de
police et de gendarmerie autant de
drames évitées et nous sommes allés sur
les bracelets on tire rapprochement plus
vite que nos amis espagnols nous allons
lancer un
bracelet anti rapprochement nouvelle
génération dans les jours qui viennent
meilleur couverture de réseau autonomie
supérieure les ordonnances de protection
le nombre a augmenté de 157% depuis 2016
4000 ordonnances délivrées par an nous
sommes passés de 47 jours à 6 jours et
nous allons nous travaillons pour
obtenir une ordonnance de protection
dans les 24 heures augmentation madame
la députée des condamnations de plus de
100% depuis 2017 on est passé de 22 000
condamnations à 44000 je dois également
souligner l'excellent travail mené par
Madame Chandler et madame la sénatrice
Verrien et nous allons tirer des
conséquences dans les jours dans les
semaines et dans les mois qui viennent
la députée la victime s'était rendu deux
fois au commissariat récemment depuis en
début mai je pense surtout à la peur
quotidienne et terrible de ces femmes et
il faudrait vraiment monsieur le
ministre monsieur le garde des sceaux
faire encore plus je vous remercie la
parole est à Monsieur Jimmy pain pour le
groupe démocrate merci merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur le Ministre la transition
écologique hier a débuté à Paris la
deuxième session de négociation du
traité contre la pollution plastique le
monde s'est donné pour objectif
d'aboutir à un accord l'année prochaine
un accord que la France au sein de la
coalition de haute ambition emmenée par
le Rwanda et la Norvège souhaite
contraignant et ambitieux
avec plusieurs groupes politiques le
groupe démocrate a lancé un appel en
faveur d'un tel traité avec nos
collègues de renaissance LFI horizon PS
écologiste GDR Eliot nous avons ainsi
appelé à soutenir des objectifs de la
coalition qui regroupe aujourd'hui plus
de 50 pays d'abord la réduction de la
production de la consommation de
plastique ensuite
l'éco-conception des plastiques et enfin
une collecte et un recyclage efficient
monsieur le ministre toute cette semaine
nos pensées accompagneront les
négociateurs français et ceux de nos
partenaires de la coalition de la
coalition car Paris devra d'ores et déjà
poser des jalons d'un traité
contraignant et ambitieux la solution
c'est donc la réduction la réduction
encore la réduction par la suppression
des polymères et des additifs
problématiques toxiques et non
recyclables est à la révolution des
usages c'est ça l'esprit des lois avec
et climat la France a ainsi une
législation de la lutte contre la
pollution plastique il faut maintenant
assurer sa bonne application et quand
c'est nécessaire prendre des mesures
complémentaires pour garantir l'atteinte
des objectifs fixés 100% des plastiques
recyclés en 2025 et 0 plastique à usage
unique en 2040 l'accompagnement public
des entreprises sera un facteur de
réussite de cette rapide mais
indispensable transition monsieur le
ministre comment garantir l'atteinte de
ses objectifs et le respect des
obligations et interdictions des lois
Ajac et climats alors que la production
plastique augmente tous les jours je
vous remercie merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur
Christophe Béchu ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
par un merci pour votre question merci
surtout pour l'initiative transpartizane
que vous avez prise et qui s'inscrit
dans la continuité d'une PPL que vous
aviez déposé ici même et de ce combat
contre le plastique que vous menez sans
doute contenu de votre position
privilégiée dans le Morbihan pour
mesurer une partie de ses effets 85% de
la pollution de nos océans est constitué
du plastique
en l'espace de 50 ans ce sont 7
milliards de tonnes de plastique qui se
sont répandus dans la nature à l'échelle
de la planète et vous l'avez dit non
seulement on continue à avoir une
production de plastique qui se qui
augmente mais avec des chiffres qui sont
alarmants contre les prolonge puisqu'en
2060 entre 2050 et 2060 pour les experts
il se passera deux choses si on change
rien ça représentera 10% de nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
plus emblématique ou inquiétant encore
le poids du plastique dans les océans
pourrait dépasser la masse des poissons
prendre cet impact c'est évidemment
faire en sorte à l'échelle mondiale de
se mobiliser 80% des plastiques
franchissent au moins une frontière dans
leur vie tout l'enjeu de ce qui est en
train de se passer avec ce deuxième
cycle de négociation c'est bien de poser
les bases de ce traité qui doit être
contraignant qui doit être ambitieux et
qui doit être assorti dans mécanisme de
contrôle la coalition à laquelle la
France appartient dirigée par le Rwanda
et la Norvège vise tous ses objectifs
nous avons eu la satisfaction de voir le
Japon nous rejoindre avant-hier mais le
travail est de longue haleine parce que
s'il n'y a pas de plastique oceptique au
niveau des individus certains pays
producteurs sont évidemment nettement
moins allant que ne le sont l'Europe et
l'Afrique qui globalement sur ce sujet
sont très alignés le soutien des
parlementaires et crucial la France dans
ce domaine je ne dirais pas qu'elle est
exemplaire parce qu'on a encore des
marges de progression mais il y a des
initiatives qu'on peut valoriser
notamment comme le fait d'être devenu le
premier pays au monde à avoir interdit
au 1er janvier la vais selle jetable
dans les dieux de restauration rapide
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Sébastien Jumel
pour le groupe GDR
[Applaudissements]
présidente ministre sur la réforme des
retraites les Français attendent un vrai
vote à l'assemblée pas de blabla pas de
combine on n'en veut plus de vous on en
peut plus de vous juste un vote hors
depuis janvier vous mobilisez toute la
gamme des artifices de procédure en
allant gratter les fonds de tiroirs pour
corps sauter le débat pour empêcher la
voix de ceux qui sont opposés à votre
projet d'impôt sur la vie pour empêcher
que un vote ne vienne balayer ce texte
ni justifié
et peut défendable vous avez gagné du
temps vous avez tenté de discréditer vos
propositions parce que vous n'aimez pas
la contradiction vous n'aimez pas le
débat vous n'avez pas la démocratie vous
rêvez même de supprimer les
contre-pouvoirs vous avez refusé un vote
pour ne pas le perdre avec le 49-3
demain en commission le 8 juin ici c'est
une séance de rattrapage les Français
l'attendent les Français vous regardent
alors
soit en démocrate vous assumez le risque
du vote soit vous continuez à raser des
murs et inventer une nouvelle partie de
billard à trois bandes pour éviter
encore l'expression d'une décision
pleinement démocratique
si vous prenez ce chemin les Français
vous verront ils verront votre lâcheté
politique et vous traînerez non plus des
casseroles mais un boulet pour
l'histoire si vous prenez ce chemin
alors que déjà les Français ne vous
supportent plus vous accentirez la crise
démocratique nous vous invitons nous le
groupe communiste solennellement à
laisser se dérouler pleinement l'examen
de cette loi en rappelant que jamais un
gouvernement aucune majorité ne s'est
réfugiée derrière l'article 40 d'une
proposition de loi d'un groupe dans sa
journée d'initiative parlementaire ne
prenez pas deux ans de vie aux Français
en vous cachant derrière cet article
comme vous l'avez déjà fait derrière le
49-3
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier du soft
ministre du Travail du plein emploi et
de l'insertion
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Député jumelle c'est le député jumelles
permettez-moi d'abord de ne pas préjugé
du débat qui se déroulera en commission
sur la proposition de loi ni de la suite
de l'examen de ce texte j'ai dit tout à
l'heure en réponse un premier
intervenant qu'à nos yeux aux yeux du
gouvernement cette proposition de loi
crée manifestement une charge très forte
sur les finances publiques en 15
milliards d'euros ce qui a notre sens
justifie de son ircevabilité et de son
caractère inconstitutionnel
pardonnez-moi mais je voudrais monsieur
le député si vous le permettez pointer
deux contradictions dans la question que
vous avez posée la première monsieur le
député vous nous dites faire droit à la
constitution serait avoir recours à des
subterfuges constitutionnels et gagner
du temps en réalité vous avez dit
fantiroir je le confirme en réalité
monsieur le député qui dans cette
hémicycle là pendant tout le débat sur
la réforme des retraites fait le pari de
l'obstruction et du ralentissement du
débat qui a déposé 20 000 amendements
les 20000 amendements venaient de la
nupasse au-delà de cela monsieur le
député il y a une deuxième contradiction
que je voulais entre la position vous
avez défendu pendant le débat sur les
retraites et le texte que vous costumiez
avec Charles Amédée de Courson vous avez
pendant tous descendu dans l'hémicycle
une position qui consistait à défendre
la retraite à 60 ans vous signez le loi
là une proposition de loi qui garde la
retraite à 62 ans vous avez fait
campagne monsieur le député vous vous
êtes mobilisés pour défendre les régies
spéciaux vous signez une proposition de
loi qui maintient la fermeture des
régimes spéciaux c'est une contradiction
et finalement une forme de reniement
monsieur le député deux secondes
l'article 40 vu par le gouvernement si
l'article des 40 voleurs des deux points
des deux envies qu'ils veulent voler aux
Français
la parole est à Madame Claudia Rouault
pour le groupe socialiste
madame la Première ministre la crise du
logement est une réalité constatée par
les professionnels de l'immobilier les
organismes HLM les élus locaux qui vous
alertent les uns après les autres sur
l'urgence de la situation en matière de
logement social la Fondation a les
pierres Abbé Pierre vient de tirer la
sonnette d'alarme car la situation est
catastrophique faut-il rappeler que 2,3
millions de ménages attendent un
logement social et que notre pays compte
4 millions de mal logés alors oui il y a
urgence à relancer ce secteur à travers
une politique de l'habitat ambitieuse et
volontariste c'est une question de
dignité pour permettre à tout à chacun
de se loger depuis 2017 les offices
publics de l'habitat font les frais
d'une politique qui a constitué consisté
à les fragiliser à travers le dispositif
de réduction de loyer de solidarité la
baisse des APL ou encore l'augmentation
de la TVA sur la construction à cela
s'ajoute la crise de l'énergie
l'inflation des coûts de construction et
de rénovation du parc social ainsi que
la forte augmentation du taux du livret
A certes bienvenue pour les particuliers
mais qui pèsent sur le financement du
logement social face à ce constat
implacable un triple enjeu doit être
relevé favoriser la relance de la
construction de logements sociaux
accélérer la rénovation du parc HLM pour
remplir nos objectifs en matière de
transition écologique développer une
approche décentralisée tenant compte de
la diversité des territoires investir
dans le logement social c'est agir pour
le pouvoir d'achat lutter contre les
inégalités sociales renforcer la
sobriété énergétique et soutenir le
secteur du bâtiment alors que les
conclusions du Conseil national de la
refondation sur le logement sont
attendus le 5 juin prochain madame la
Premier ministre a quand un débat au
Parlement pour entendre nos propositions
quel engagement fort prenez vous pour
relancer dès à présent ce secteur je
vous remercie merci beaucoup ma chère
collègues la parole est à Monsieur
Olivier Klein ministre délégué chargé de
la ville et du logement
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Rouault madame la Première ministre l'a
dit tout à l'heure la crise du logement
est réelle nous ne la contestons pas et
nous travaillons dessus depuis des mois
mais le gouvernement a agi le
gouvernement agi depuis le quinquennat
précédent ma prime rénove c'est ce
gouvernement et cette majorité qu'il a
mis en place le plafonnement du loyer
lors de la loi sur le pouvoir d'achat
c'est ce gouvernement qui l'a mise en
place l'augmentation de 3 et demi pour
cent des aPL lors de la loi pouvoir
d'achat c'est ce gouvernement qui l'a
mise en place
le travail sur l'évolution et
l'amélioration de ma prime rénov c'est
ce gouvernement qui la met en place la
mise en place la mise en place du crédit
éco PTZ pour les plus fragiles pour
accompagner ma primeur c'est aussi ce
gouvernement qui la met en place vous
l'avez rappelé le 5 juin prochain et la
première ministre vous a dit qu'il y a
assistera et ça montre l'importance que
nous attachons au dossier du logement
nous serons
nous remettrons la restitution du
Conseil national de refondation qui a
fait travailler plus de 200 acteurs du
logement sur ces questions christophe
Robert il y a quelques jours disait que
c'était un moment exceptionnel de
mobilisation de l'ensemble des acteurs
tels qu'ils ne l'avait lui-même j'avais
connu et j'étais il y a quelques jours
avec la Fondation Abbé Pierre à
l'inauguration d'une pension de famille
à estreville dans la résidence chère à
l'abbé Pierre et je peux vous assurer
que l'accueil de la Fondation a été de
grande qualité donc nous allons
continuer à travailler avec la
représentation nationale qui était
d'ailleurs présente dans le Conseil
national de la qui a donné ses
propositions le CNH est présidé par l'un
d'entre vous à Lionel cosse et le
travail du CNH c'est un travail de
grande qualité qui viendra compléter les
propositions du CNR mais en attendant
sur la crise actuelle nous travaillons
bien évidemment avec Action Logement à
la signature d'une nouvelle convention
quinquennale et avec l'USH comme la
souhaiter la première ministre dans sa
feuille de route à la signature du
nouveau pacte de confiance merci merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre madame
Rouault monsieur le minute à vous
d'entendre tout va bien juste un chiffre
42 milliards pour les logements sociaux
en 2016
35,4 milliards en 2023 madame la
Première ministre puisque vous avez
proposé au Président marlex un débat et
bien des bâtons merci beaucoup ma chère
collègue la parole est à Monsieur
Florian chaude pour le groupe la France
insoumise
merci Madame merci madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre votre réforme des
retraites était censée sauver notre
système de retraite par répartition elle
devait permettre de combler le déficit à
venir 12 milliards d'économies par an
d'après Gabriel Attal en janvier 18
milliards pour Olivier dussoft en
février aujourd'hui la Cour des comptes
estime que la réforme se traduira par un
surcoût jusqu'à la fin 2024 un Ganet
limité à un milliard d'euros en 2025 et
au mieux à 7 milliards d'euros en 2030
vous deviez combler le déficit c'est
raté vous faites travailler les Français
deux ans de plus sans solutionner le
problème si vous voulez sauver notre
système de retraite par répartition
augmentez les salaires arrêtez les
cadeaux aux grandes entreprises
supprimer les exonérations de
cotisations
inutiles et faites participer ceux qui
en ont les moyens
le 8 juin le groupe liotte utilisera sa
niche parlementaire pour abroger votre
réforme et permettre l'organisation
d'une conférence sur le financement de
notre système de retraite c'est la voie
du dialogue et de l'apaisement vous
devriez la saisir au lieu de cela vous
continuez votre passage en force et vous
avez méprisé les organisations
syndicales vous avez fait passer votre
réforme contre l'avis des français et
vous voudriez aujourd'hui bâillonner
notre assemblée les déclarations de
ministres les déclarations de ministres
déclarant inconstitutionnels cette
proposition de loi dont la vôtre madame
la Première ministre se multiplie ce
matin c'est la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale qui déclarait qui n'est pas il
ne doit pas y avoir de débat sur cet
article qui est clairement
anticonstitutionnel
ne vous en déplaise ni les membres du
gouvernement ni vous madame la
Présidente n'est apte à juger de la
constitutionnalité de cette proposition
de loi d'ailleurs vous l'avez jugé
recevable il y a quelques semaines votre
peur de voir notre assemblée voter la
progression de la réforme des retraites
vous conduit au pire excès il faut
savoir raison garder le président de la
commission des finances a jugé la
proposition de loi recevable nous devons
maintenant débattre de cette proposition
de loi et voter d'ici là les Français
manifesteront mardi prochain pour vous
dire encore une fois leur opposition à
cette réforme et nous verrons jeudi 8
quelle est la vie de l'Assemblée
nationale merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur
Olivier du soft le ministre du Travail
de plein emploi et de l'insertion merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le Député
Sosh c'est le député vous avez donné
lecture d'une partie des éléments du
rapport annuel de l'accord des comptes
sur la loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale en réalité monsieur le député ce
texte et ce document de la Cour des
comptes devrait vous satisfaire
satisfaire parce que que dit-il il dit
que l'effet de la réforme que nous avons
votée est progressif c'est la
démonstration qu'elle n'a pas la
brutalité que vous lui prétendez il dit
que c'était fait va avoir un coût à
court terme c'est vrai c'est la
traduction dès le mois de septembre de
la revalorisation des petites retraites
de la meilleure prise en compte des
carrières longues de l'ouverture de la
retraite progressive ça aussi vous
devriez vous en satisfaire ce même
rapport annuel de la Cour des comptes il
s'intéresse au régime du régime au sol
du régime général ce qu'on appelle
parfois le régime de base si vous aviez
lu le rapport dans son intégralité vous
verriez que ce qu'on regarde cela tout
régime confondu l'équilibre financier
est bien au rendez-vous tous les
chiffres que vous avez cités qui sont
ceux du rappeur annuel ils sont aussi
dans l'étude d'impact du projet loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale c'est
la démonstration que vous auriez dû le
lire avant de vous prêter un tel procès
contre ce projet de loi la réforme que
nous avons présenté permet de garantir
l'avenir du système de répartition la
proposition de loi que vous voulez voter
le mettrez à mal nous allons continuer à
nous opposer à cette mauvaise
proposition de loi elle est aussi
irrecevable qui est respons able et
c'est tout le sens du débat qu'on aura
dans les prochains jours je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est un monsieur
Stéphane Buchou pour le groupe
Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur François Braun ministre de la
Santé de la prévention monsieur le
ministre en raison d'un afflux important
de patients et d'un nombre insuffisants
de bras pour les prendre en charge les
services d'urgence du département de la
Vendée ont dû à l'instar d'autres
territoires permettent temporairement
plusieurs heures ces dernières semaines
au sable d'Olonne dans ma
circonscription après la nuit de samedi
à dimanche dernier ce sera encore
malheureusement le cas entre ce soir et
demain matin d'autres villes du
département sont malheureusement
touchées et concernés par ces fermetures
en pointillés annoncées peu de temps en
amont de leur effectivité cela génère de
l'anxiété et alimente l'angoisse des
familles et des patients pour qui la
prise en charge doit parfois être rapide
j'ai rencontré il y a une quinzaine de
jours les équipes médicales et la
direction de l'hôpital des
Sables-d'Olonne je veux ici bien
évidemment souligner leur engagement de
chaque instant et leur dévouement au
service de la population à l'image de
l'ensemble de la communauté médicale je
veux aussi témoigner du travail réalisé
afin de palier au mieux les difficultés
rencontrées et anticiper les vacances
d'été parce qu'en même temps que les
réservations dans nos campings battent
leur plein les plannings des centres
hospitaliers eux ont beaucoup de mal à
se remplir les causes nous les
connaissons et pour beaucoup d'entre
elles ne doivent pas d'hier les
professionnels que j'ai rencontrés le
savent et il salue d'ailleurs les
mesures que nous avons courageusement
prises malheureusement elles ne portent
pas leurs fruits suffisamment vite qu'il
s'agisse de la suppression du numerus
clausus ou celle issues de la
proposition de loi de notre collègue
Stéphanie Rist j'ai donc entendu leur
crainte j'en partage un certain nombre
et au travers de ma question je voulais
relai monsieur le ministre je ne me veut
ni démesurément à l'armiste ni
totalement fataliste laissant penser que
nous ne sommes pas en mesure de faire
face mais alors que beaucoup de nos
compatriotes s'apprêtent à partir en
vacances sur nos littoraux quelles sont
les mesures envisagées par le
gouvernement afin de prévenir ces
situations et éviter qu'elles ne se
reproduise est-il par exemple
envisageable de favoriser la mobilité du
personnel soignant dans les territoires
qui vont bientôt voir leur population
augmenter très fortement je vous
remercie
je vous remercie mes chers collègues la
parole est à Monsieur François brode
ministre de la Santé de la prévention
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Stéphane Buchoud je vous remercie
d'avoir salué l'engagement des
professionnels des services d'urgence
qui effectivement reste sur le pont je
rappelle simplement la crise de l'été
dernier sur les terrorités de la
première ministre nous avons été amené à
apprendre à certains nombre de mesures
en particulier la promotion de la
régulation médicale la régulation
médicale c'est quoi c'est avant de se
déplacer aux urgences dire à nos
concitoyens d'appeler le 15 parce que
partout sur le territoire quel que soit
l'heure du jour et de la nuit en a plein
le 15 vous avez un médecin au téléphone
qui vous proposera la solution la plus
adaptée à votre problème de santé et en
fonction de chaque territoire
en complément de cette promotion du 15
nous avons revalorisé les horaires de
nuit pour prendre en compte la
pénibilité nous avons revalorisé les
actes qui sont réalisés par les médecins
généralistes que je veux également
saluer parce qu'ils se sont organisés
pour prendre en charge les urgences et
nous avons développé des outils de
télémédecine pour la première fois
depuis 20 ans l'été dernier la
fréquentation des services d'urgence a
enfin diminué en grande partie liées à
ces mesures à un investissement des
professionnels en complément bien sûr
nous continuons à travailler sur
l'attractivité de ces métiers de
l'urgence qui sont des métiers
particulièrement pénibles la lutte
contre l'intérim médical a permis de
mobiliser deux leviers le premier fait
revenir à l'hôpital dans les équipes des
professionnels pour travailler de façon
plus pérenne et enfin mettent en place
cette solidarité territoriale dont je
veux continuer la promotion et qui
permet de mieux répondre aussi à
l'ensemble des territoires une chose à
préciser toutefois et qui sera également
maintenu cet été c'est que la réponse à
l'aide médicale urgente c'est-à-dire la
réponse
un véritable situation d'urgence qu'elle
soit vitale ou qu'elle soit
fonctionnelle et maintenu voire
renforcer dans les territoires
d'ailleurs qu'il y a des changements de
population et c'est ça qui est le plus
important l'engagement du président de
la République qui a été pris pour
désaturer nos services d'urgence à
échelon fin 2024 sera obtenu par cette
régulation médicale qui se généralise au
sein des services d'accès aux soins sur
l'ensemble du territoire par
l'amélioration du fonctionnement de
l'hôpital et également en moindre part
par la majoration de nos services
d'urgence auquel nous contribuons je
vous remercie
madame excusez-moi excusez-moi j'ai
souhaité une ligne je suis navré voilà
c'est pour ça
oh non
excusez-moi monsieur Laurent Pagny fou
pour le groupe Liath désolé mon cher
collègue merci madame la Présidente vous
êtes toutes pardonnée madame la Première
ministre
mes chers collègues s'adressent ma
question à Monsieur le Ministre des
Colonies des Finances à défaut à
Monsieur le Ministre des Solidarités de
l'autonomie monsieur le ministre chacun
connaît ici les grandes difficultés
rencontrées par les EHPAD en France que
ce soit la crise covid les immenses
problèmes de recrutement mais aussi les
difficultés financières nous concentrons
à juste titre notre attention sur la
bien traitance qui doit prévaloir dans
nos établissements sur la qualité
d'accueil de soins et plus largement la
qualité de l'accompagnement que nous
sommes en droit d'exiger de ces
structures mais pour que cette exigence
soit crédible monsieur le ministre
législateur gouvernement et
administration doivent créer les
conditions d'un exercice réaliste de ces
métiers en leur donnant notamment un
cadre réglementaire financier budgétaire
mais aussi fiscal suffisant et stable à
la hauteur de l'enjeu que représente
l'accompagnement dans la dignité de nos
aînés or le ministère des Finances a
décidé de remettre en cause la capacité
des EHPAD public à bénéficier du régime
de la TVA sachant que ce régime fiscal
avait pour effet de permettre à ces
établissements de bénéficier de la
récupération de la TVA sur les dépenses
d'investissement et partiellement sur
les dépenses d'exploitation mais aussi
et peut-être surtout générer une
exonération de la taxe sur les salaires
dont bénéficie toujours le secteur privé
par ailleurs ajoutez à cela le rappel
sur les années précédentes les trois
comme d'usage en matière fiscale les
sommes en jeu sont alors considérables
voire fatale pour des établissements
publics à qui l'administration fiscale
avait pourtant validé l'application de
ce régime depuis de nombreuses années si
je prends l'exemple de les portes
d'Ariège Pyrénées que je viens de
quitter structure de 200 places les
sommes dues suite à cette décision
unilatérale de Bercy approche le million
d'euros je me tourne donc vers vous
monsieur le ministre afin qu'une
décision soit prise au plus vite pour
soulager ces établissements publics déjà
en grande difficulté et pour qu'il cette
mesure et sa rétroactivité sera
probablement celle de trop je vous
remercie je vous remercie mon cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Christophe con ministre des
Solidarités de l'autonomie et des
personnes handicapées merci mesdames la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le députés penifou
merci pour votre question qui me permet
d'abord de saluer le travail
exceptionnel de nos EHPAD dans un
contexte particulier je le sais avec le
soutien des services de l'État mais
aussi des élus comme chez vous ces EHPAD
exercent un accompagnement des personnes
âgées de nous aînés dans un contexte
difficile vous l'avez dit à cause des
questions de défiance liées à la crise
sanitaire liée à l'affaire hors pai donc
un taux d'occupation extrêmement bas
pour un certain nombre d'entre eux mais
aussi des difficultés économiques liées
à la tractivité des métiers ou encore à
l'inflation votre question elle aborde
également la question d'une difficulté
plus récente à cause d'une décision du
Conseil d'État qui confirme la
sujetissement des établissements publics
à la taxe sur les salaires
assujettissement qui a conduit à des
situations extrêmement graves puisque
certains établissements ont des arriérés
qui datent de plusieurs années et donc
on pesait sur la trésorerie de ces
établissements des confirmations de
cette décision nous avons avec mon
collègue chargé des comptes publics
saisis nos administrations pour faire un
point précis sur la situation notamment
savoir combien d'epad et dans quelle
proportion était était concerné et puis
nous sommes également en train d'étudier
les souplesse de recouvrement pour
pouvoir accompagner ces établissements
et faire en sorte qu'ils ne se
retrouvent pas dans des difficultés qui
seraient
insurmontables ce soutien il s'est déjà
matérialisé depuis plusieurs mois
notamment en fin d'année avec
l'abondement de crédit supplémentaire en
fin d'exercice qui ont été délégués par
l'État le bouclier tarifaire qui a été
étendu à l'ensemble des établissements
médico-sociaux ou encore le soutien
spécifique des agences régionales de
santé qui ont triplé leur crédits
délégués en soutien à l'ensemble de nos
EHPAD ce soutien il passera enfin de
façon plus durable et structurelle par
une réflexion que nous allons conduire
sur le modèle économique des EHPAD en
lien avec les départements pour leur
apporter une réponse et une solution
définitive merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Madame Sophie
tailler paulian pour le groupe
écologiste merci madame merci madame la
Présidente je voudrais féliciter madame
Justine trier pour la Palme d'or qu'elle
a reçu samedi
dans son discours elle a précisé à quel
point son oeuvre n'aurait pu voir le
jour sans l'exception culturelle et
combien cette dernière avait du mal à
endiguer la marchandisation de la
culture s'inquiétant pour les jeunes
réalisateurs
elle a surtout osé crème de crime de lez
ma chronique exprimée ce qui pèse sur le
cœur de tant de Françaises et de
français une réforme des retraites
injustes passées en force selon moi elle
a raison selon vous madame la ministre
de la Culture elle a certainement tort
mais là n'est pas la question
l'exception culturelle est un système
que le monde nous envie qui contribue à
notre rayonnement culturel parce qu'il
permet la création hors des logiques de
rentabilité marchande et c'est aussi le
triomphe d'après-guerre de
l'indépendance de la culture face aux
tentations autoritaires de faire de
l'art un outil de propagande du pouvoir
grâce à elle les artistes n'ont pas à
plaire à ceux qui les gouvernent et
grâce à elle le cinéma français est bien
vivant c'est pourquoi madame la ministre
quand je vous entends parler
d'ingratitude cela me choque
profondément accusez des artistes ayant
bénéficié d'aide publique d'ingratitude
c'est sous-entendre que ce terre devrait
être la contrepartie des aides dans un
contexte où Laurent qui est à juste
supprimer les subventions au théâtre
nouvelle génération parce que les propos
de son directeurs ne lui avaient pas plu
une ministre de la Culture ne devrait
pas dire ça vous devriez vous tenir au
côté de la libre expression des artistes
quand bien même elle n'est vous ne
seriez pas d'accord avec leur prise de
position aussi nous attendons de votre
part la condamnation ferme de la
multitude de propos issus de la majorité
visant à faire taire les artistes
subventionnés je pense notamment aux
présidents de la commission des affaires
économiques au ministre de l'Industrie
qui quand il s'agit de demander aux
grandes entreprises ou valargens et ben
il y a plus personne merci beaucoup ma
chère collègues la parole est à Madame
Rima Abdoul Malak ministre de la Culture
merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée
à la liberté d'expression je viens de le
dire à votre collègue Sarah le grain qui
a un principe intangible de notre
démocratie mais je trouve important de
rétablir la vérité quand il y a sur le
fond des propos qui sont ultra excessifs
par rapport à la réalité où sont
aujourd'hui les menaces qui pèsent sur
la culture où sont les dangers vous avez
un parti qui veut censurer des artistes
qui veut boycotter des journalistes qui
veut conditionner les aides de CNC à des
films qui feraient la promotion de
l'histoire de France a été dit en
commission des affaires culturelles vous
avez un parti qui veut privatiser
l'audiovisuel public quand on sait à
quel point l'audioval public finance la
création à hauteur de 500 millions
d'euros par an et vous avez un président
de région vous l'avez mentionné qui
distribue des bons points des mauvais
points et qui décident de couper des
subventions à ceux qui s'expriment en
désaccord contre lui voilà les dérives
autoritaires voilà les dérives qui
menacent notre modèle culturel la
ministre que vous avez face à vous
défend le plus haut budget que la
culture a obtenu depuis que le ministère
de la Culture existe plus 7% par rapport
à l'année dernière la ministre de la
Culture que vous allez devant vous
défend la liberté de création à chaque
fois qu'elle est menacée la ministre de
la Culture que vous avez devant vous est
aux côtés des élus et des collectivités
de la région Verne Rhône-Alpes pour
trouver des solutions je vais vous
donner un exemple il y a quelques
semaines une tribune a été signée par un
certain nombre d'artistes de
professionnels de la culture contre la
réforme des retraites ils ne sont pas
d'accord avec le gouvernement ils ne
sont pas d'accord avec nous est-ce que
vous pouvez regarder le détail de cette
liste vous verrez qu'il y a énormément
de directeurs d'institutions
subventionnés que nous subventionnons
est-ce que nous avons baissé leur
subventions est-ce que nous avons dit
quelque chose évidemment que non
évidemment que non nous les avons même
augmenté pour faire face à l'inflation
je pourrais vous donner la liste donc
vous voyez bien ça n'a jamais été un
critère merci beaucoup madame la
ministre
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Madame Christine en
grand pour le rassemblement national
[Applaudissements]
madame la ministre Olivier agrégoire
chers collègues les TPE sont aux abois
le nombre de défaillances d'entreprises
augmente de 43,6 % au premier trimestre
2023 par rapport à celui de 2022 et 80
pour 12% d'entre elles concernent des
sociétés de moins de 10 salariés selon
le cabinet alteres peut-être aurait-elle
été entendue si ces informations
provenaient du cabinet mckinsee ici
présente aujourd'hui dans l'hémicycle
Céline chef d'entreprise de Colombie
dans le Pas-de-Calais Fatima chef
d'entreprise à l'Indre dans le
Pas-de-Calais dans ma circonscription
ont écrit au Président de la République
en tout début d'année et non eu à ce
jour pour seule réponse qu'un silence
assourdissant depuis plusieurs mois la
première et son mari ne perce plus de
salaire les raisons c'est l'île vous les
a exposés dans son courrier aujourd'hui
bon nombre d'entreprises coulent cool
sous les charges les dettes les coûts de
l'énergie les coûts des matériaux les
emprunts que les banques accordent plus
la feuille de placo est passée de 90
centimes à le taux d'usure est passé en
quelques mois de 2% à plus de 4%. les
tuiles s'achètent aux enchères la
seconde Fatima est à la tête d'une TPE
de nettoyage de 10 salariés créés il y a
40 ans elle a voté pour vous et elle
vous a écrit je cite un appel au secours
d'un couple d'entrepreneurs qui perd ses
moyens afin de dénoncer les charges qui
les écrasent et la hausse du SMIC en
contrepartie qui les étouffent ce qui ne
serait pas arrivé avec notre proposition
de hausse des salaires jusqu'à trois
fois le SMIC exonéré des cotisations
sociales pas très mal pardon tous deux
dénoncent une absence du gouvernement
qui je cite croit que le petit ne peut
arriver à rien et donne tout au gros ses
propos ne sont que ce ne sont pas les
nôtres mais les leurs et pourtant ils
reprennent point par point ce que nous
dénonçons depuis des mois voire des
années incapable de trouver des
solutions le même gouvernement qui
promettait une retraite à 1200 euros
pour tous pendant la campagne
présidentielle préfère tenter une
acquisition contre le rassemblement le
rassemblement national c'est oublier que
si nos idées sont populaires c'est
qu'elles proviennent des Français qui
travaillent et qui entreprennent avec
une question qui subsiste quand est-ce
que vous vous intéresserez à eux et
quels sont vos propositions concrètes à
mettre en œuvre immédiatement avant
qu'il ne soit définitivement trop tard
merci
la parole est à Madame Olivia Grégoire
ministre délégué chargé des PME du
Commerce de l'Artisanat et du Tourisme
merci madame la présidente madame la
députée en grand
d'abord je voudrais vous dire à
l'endroit des deux entrepreneurs que
vous mentionnez que c'est très bien
d'écrire au président de la République
mais je suis à leur disposition on peut
m'écrire au 139 rue de Bercy Paris 12e
arrondissement et je vous garantis qu'on
répond à chacun des courriers par
ailleurs pour ce qui est des difficultés
si vos collègues si vos collègues me
laissent éventuellement en finir je dis
ça pour apporter une réponse précise aux
difficultés qu'elle rencontre
j'ajouterai aux côtés des onomatopées
charmantes de Monsieur Chenu que c'est
pour être plus efficiente que je réponds
pour être plus efficace dans chaque
département vous avez des entreprises
qui connaissent des difficultés dans
chaque département vous avez dans chaque
préfecture un conseiller départemental à
la sortie de crise tous les jours c'est
conseillé tous les jours accompagnent
des entrepreneurs en difficulté assure
des
échelonnements des créances assurent la
mise en place de l'amortisseur du
bouclier tarifaire et accompagne les PME
en difficulté vous citez aujourd'hui une
étude qui est une étude d'alteres alors
je vous dirais je vais pas vous citer
l'intégralité des études que le
ministère de l'Économie a en main parce
qu'il y en a beaucoup et que par
honnêteté intellectuelle ça dépend et du
secteur et de la taille des entreprises
et des questions qu'on leur pose il y a
un chiffre qui a été partagé aujourd'hui
par l'Observatoire du financement ça ne
vous a pas échappé et aussi par une
étude de la BPI vous avez une réalité au
mois de février dernier l'accès au
crédit de nos PME de nos TPE a augmenté
de 5%. vous avez aussi des entrepreneurs
qui sont pour certains en difficulté
mais qui sont confiants avec 7 points de
plus sur la situation de leur trésorerie
futur alors qu'il y ait et je pense
qu'on peut se mettre d'accord là-dessus
des entreprises qui rencontrent des
difficultés il y en a mais l'immense
majorité de nos TPE de nos PME arrive à
rembourser leur PGE arrive à être
accompagné et arrive à vendre et à
exporter je suis plus que disponible
pour accompagner les deux que vous avez
mentionné et je me tiens à leur
disposition à l'adresse mentionnée merci
beaucoup madame la ministre la parole
est à Madame Sophie met pour le groupe
démocrate
[Applaudissements]
grand paliés il est crucial de faire
connaître nos ateliers d'encourager la
création française de valoriser ces
métiers auprès des jeunes et de donner
une réponse à cette orientation une
partie de ces défis doit être relevée
par l'outil puissant de démocratisation
culturelle qui est le Pass Culture en
quoi consiste les nouvelles activités
d'initiation que vous proposerez à notre
jeunesse enfin rappelons que les métiers
d'art s'inscrivent contre la production
de masse et jetables le recyclage de
plastique est courant ainsi que la
réutilisation de chutes de tissu ou même
de matière organique c'est notre rôle
que d'encourager les pratiques durables
cela passe par le développement de
réseaux de proximité par une logique
d'économie circulaire et de production
locale comment mettre en place des
mesures efficaces qui se déclineront sur
tous nos territoires et notamment dans
la ruralité je vous remercie merci
beaucoup ma chère collègue la parole est
à Madame Rima Abdelmalek ministre de la
Culture
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Sophie meth et merci de sa Thomas à nos
artisans d'art et à ses 281 métiers qui
font le la force des savoir-faire de nos
régions et le rayonnement de la France à
l'international nous avons lancé ce
matin avec ma collègue Olivia Grégoire
une stratégie nationale pour les métiers
d'art sur laquelle nous travaillons
depuis plusieurs mois en fédérant tous
les professionnels des différents
écosystèmes de ces métiers publiques
comme privé avec un une priorité
effectivement comme vous l'avez dit sur
la relève sur la jeunesse sur la
transmission de ces métiers aux
nouvelles générations ça va passer par
des stages et des ateliers découvertes à
l'école ça va passer par la mobilisation
de nos institutions culturelles comme le
Mobilier national par exemple qui lance
le petit mob des ateliers pour les
enfants et les adolescents ça va passer
aussi par le Pass Culture avec plus de
700 activités métiers d'art qui vont
être proposés aux jeunes entre 15 et 19
ans pour ce qui est des territoires
c'est le deuxième axe le plus
prioritaire de notre stratégie avec
notamment le déploiement via le plan
France 2030 d'un appel à projet pour
créer des pôles territoriaux de métiers
d'art la relance des manufactures de
proximité qui ont été lancés pendant le
plan de relance qui vont être déployés
dans d'autres départements et un travail
sur le label Entreprise du Patrimoine
Vivant pour le renforcer encore plus une
redynamisation aussi des Journées
européennes des métiers d'art et tout un
volet à l'international pour faciliter
l'exportation de ces métiers faciliter
des expositions facilités des résidences
à l'étranger faciliter les présences sur
les salons et continuer à porter haut et
fort cette ambition pour la culture et
l'économie à travers l'artisanat merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup madame la
ministre la parole est à Madame Manon
meunier pour la France insoumise
madame la Première ministre vous êtes à
contre-courant de l'histoire en pleine
urgence écologique vous relancez le
charbon et le gaz vous soutenez les
multinationales d'énergie fossiles après
tout on a le temps il y a deux semaines
vous avez même proclamé la pause
environnementale reprise en grande pompe
par votre président car pour flatter la
sainte concurrence et les marchés rien
n'est trop bon et après tout il n'y a
pas d'urgence et pourtant ce jeudi les
scientifiques ont découvert que le
ralentissement des courants océaniques
profonds entraînés par la fonte des
glaces et beaucoup plus rapide que prévu
alors en quoi cela nous concerne et bien
l'océan est à la fois un formidable puis
de carbone et le premier poumon de la
planète puisqu'il nous apporte plus de
50% de l'oxygène que nous respirons et
ce grâce à un fragile équilibre entre la
biodiversité marine et ces fameux
courants océaniques profonds qui font
circuler carbone et oxygène
alors le ralentissement de ces courants
océaniques c'est grave oui c'est grave
car cela met en danger la vie marine et
remet en cause le rôle depuis de carbone
joué par l'océan et cela aggrave donc
encore plus le changement climatique
en bref nous pensions qu'il y avait
urgence à agir mais c'est encore pire
que cela
alors admettons admettons que vous
n'ayez pas ces îles urgences au bout de
milliers de crises d'alerte
scientifiques au bout de deux
condamnations pour une action climatique
au bout de six rapports du GIEC mais
maintenant il est plus que temps de
sortir de votre déni car croyez moi
chers collègues madame la ministre je
vous le dis en toute bienveillance les
décisions que vous prenez ne sont pas
sans conséquence elle déterminent les
conditions futures d'habitabilité pour
notre planète elle détermine l'avenir
des milliards d'être humains qui
peuplent cette terre madame la Première
ministre allez-vous enfin faire passer
nos vies avant leur profit
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Bérengère Couillard secrétaire d'État
chargé de l'écologie
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
meunier vous faites référence à une
étude qui a été publiée il y a quelques
jours dans une revue scientifique de
renom et cette étude elle montre que les
courants océaniques profonds
ralentissent plus rapidement que prévu
en effet ce phénomène de ralentissement
est notamment lié à la fonte des glaces
de l'Antarctique c'est une conséquence
du changement climatique il est
documenté depuis plusieurs années mais
la donnée récente montre que
l'accélération du phénomène est en cours
les impacts sont nombreux moins
d'oxygène disponibles pour la
biodiversité marine moins de stockage
carbone et également le dérèglement du
climat des régions littorales le
gouvernement est pleinement engagé dans
la réduction des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre nous tiendrons la
trajectoire pour respecter l'accord de
Paris au niveau national le premier la
première ministre a présenté lors du
Conseil national de la transition
écologique du 22 mai sa vision pour une
déclinaison sectorielle et territoriale
de nos émissions nous travaillons
également sur un scénario pessimiste
mais crédible d'adaptation à plus 4
degrés en France car il nous faut
anticiper les investissements
nécessaires au niveau européen la
première ministre a encore réaffirmé la
semaine dernière pas plus tard que
vendredi auprès du commissaire européen
à l'environnement la mobilisation de la
France dans le Green Deal européen et au
niveau mondial nous préparons
actuellement la troisième conférence des
Nations unies pour l'océan qui se
tiendra à Nice en 2025 c'est un
rendez-vous international important
l'océan est à la croisée des enjeux
climatiques environnementaux et du
développement durable et pour agir
également il nous faut connaître nos
écosystèmes marins c'est pourquoi une
place centrale sera donnée au panel
international pour la durabilité de
l'océan l'équivalent du GIEC de l'océan
vous voyez madame la députée vos
accusations sont infondées le
gouvernement est pleinement mobilisé
je vous remercie madame la ministre
madame la députée
[Musique]
relance de gaz de schiste charbon vos
actions sont plus qu'inutiles elles sont
néfastes
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Hubert vu le
franc pour le groupe GDR
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre des Transports
anticipant carrément les conclusions de
l'enquête lancée en janvier dernier par
la Commission européenne vous avez
annoncé la semaine dernière la
liquidation de fret SNCF à sortie
de l'abandon de 30 % du trafic de
l'opérateur public
la suppression de 500 emplois de
cheminots ou encore la session d'actifs
aux concurrents de fret SNCF or nous
avons impérativement besoin de
développer le frais de ferroviaire pour
répondre aux défis climatiques et cette
décision et bien nous prive clairement
d'un outil industriel majeur pour le
report modal de la route vers le rail
pour donner le change vous avez annoncé
parallèlement vouloir et bien consolider
les 160 millions d'euros par an que vous
consacrez au fret et vous avez annoncé 4
milliards sur France relance un chiffre
à mettre en rapport avec les 100
milliards de soutien aux ferroviaires
que vous avez promis en février dernier
alors la logique de fuite en avant
libérale qui est la vôtre ne perdra pas
l'évidence de relever le défi climatique
les plans de relance qui se sont
succédés depuis 20 ans
pas permis à notre pays de sortir de
l'impasse du tout routier alors les
députés communistes vont déclencher une
commission d'enquête sur ce que nous
appelons une véritable capitulation
gouvernementale allez-vous et c'est ma
question enfin vous battre pour faire
évoluer les règles européennes
autorisant les États à reprendre la main
sur leur système de transport
stratégique je vous remercie mon cher
collègue la parole est à monsieur
Clément bonne ministre chargé des
transports
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
villefranc je connais votre engagement
pour le ferroviaire nous avons discuté
encore récemment sur les petites lignes
et notamment pour le frais de
ferroviaire et je le partage très
profondément parce que je crois à
l'avenir du Fred ferroviaire et d'un
Fred ferroviaire public dans notre pays
quelle est la situation c'est qu'en
effet vous l'avez rappelé la Commission
européenne engagé une procédure nous
avons cherché à l'éviter c'est
aujourd'hui malheureusement la réalité
et parce que je crois comme vous offrez
de ferroviaire je ne mentirai pas aux
salariés de Fred SNCF je ne mentirai pas
à tous ceux qui pour la transition
écologique savent que nous avons besoin
de développer le frais de ferroviaire en
France et que nous avons besoin d'un
opérateur de Fred ferroviaire public
c'est pour ça que nous devons trouver
une solution rapide et une solution qui
préserve un certain nombre de lignes
rouges il n'y aura pas d'accord au
rabais il n'y aura aucune privatisation
il n'y aura aucun licenciement il n'y
aura aucun report model à l'évidence
l'alternative disons le franchement
c'est d'attendre en effet 18 à 24 mois
ce serait la solution la facilité je le
dis très franchement de la démagogie
parce que nous ne ser pas quel est
l'avenir d'une entreprise qui investira
dans une entreprise dont l'avenir n'est
pas connu qui sera motivé pour relancer
le frais de ferroviaire si on ne sait
pas quelle est la perspective pour fêter
SNCF et si ça survit même serait assurée
dans quelques mois je ne prendrai pas ce
risque je ne jouerai pas avec l'avenir
du Fred ferroviaire c'est la raison pour
laquelle non pas pour le donner le
change non pas pour minimiser les dégâts
mais pour développer le frais de
ferroviaire et y compris celui de notre
opérateur public nous réinvestissons en
effet dans le frais de ferroviaire les
montants que vous évoquez ils sont pas
minimes monsieur le député on n'a jamais
fait ça 4 milliards d'investissements
sur 10 ans dans le frais de ferroviaire
pour nos gars le triage pour les
capillaire Fred que vous connaissez si
bien 330 millions d'euros par an le
soutient l'exploitation les frais de
ferroviaire notamment pour l'opérateur
de Fred ferroviaire public ça n'est pas
minimiser les dégâts ce n'est pas
essayer de limiter les choses c'est
préparer et bâtir ensemble un avenir
pour le frais de ferroviaire public je
vous remercie monsieur le ministre
allez-y mon cher collègue merci Madame
la président monsieur le ministre la
Dodge ban l'opérateur fait revenir
allemand est également sous le coup
d'une commission d'enquête alors le
couple franco-allemand qu'on nous vend
temps moteur de l'Europe n'est donc pas
en capacité de défendre l'intérêt
national de chacun de ces paysans je
vous remercie
la parole est à Madame constance le
griffe un monsieur le ministre
excusez-moi
[Applaudissements]
tu jettes important il mérite d'être
précis ce n'est pas le cas la Dolce
banne en effet vous avez raison et sous
le coup une procédure et à ma
connaissance nous homologues allemands
cherchent aussi à trouver une solution
rapide et discuter avec les autorités
européennes
je vous remercie donc la parole est à
Madame constance le grip pour le groupe
Renaissance
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre de la Culture oui la France
aime le cinéma le prouve et l'a toujours
prouvé notre pays inventeur du cinéma
avec les frères Lumière a toujours su
garder un cinéma fort créatif reconnu
admirer chatoyant nous pouvons être
heureux d'avoir sur notre sol le plus
grand festival de cinéma du monde le
Festival de Cannes dont la dernière
édition vient de se terminer nous
pouvons être fiers quand trois ans ce
sont deux palmes d'or qui sont venus
récompenser des films français titane de
la réalisatrice Julien duconneau et
anatomie d'une chute de la radiatrice
Justine Triet de réalisatrices c'est au
talent de ces réalisatrices bien sûr au
talent des acteurs des techniciens des
scénaristes de tous les métiers du
cinéma que l'on doit ces récompenses et
je n'oublie pas les distinctions encore
tout récemment accordées à des films
français à Berlin et à Venise mais c'est
aussi l'exception culturelle française
qui rend possible double l'éclosion des
talents qui accompagnent soutien finance
ses talents oui il y a un modèle de
financement du cinéma français né avec
André Malraux et que tous les
gouvernants tous les ministres de la
Culture successifs ont avec engagement
et volontariste poursuivi ce modèle de
financement du cinéma français unique au
monde et qui nous est tente enviés qui
combine argent public et argent privé
ils permettent la diversité de la
création le soutien aux jeunes
réalisateurs l'encouragement au tournage
et aux formations et ce sont les
Français nombreux très nombreux à se
rendre dans les salles de cinéma qui ont
retrouvé le chemin des salles de cinéma
après la pandémie qui nous le montre oui
nous aimons le cinéma n'en déplaise aux
esprits grincheux et injustes madame la
ministre pouvez-vous nous rappeler les
caractéristiques de ce modèle français
du financement du cinéma nous rappeler
également la mobilisation du
gouvernement pendant la crise du covid
ce que sont vos projets concrets en
matière de cinéma merci la parole est à
Madame rimable ministre de la Culture
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés et Madame la
Députée constance le grip merci
effectivement il faut se réjouir de la
bonne santé de notre filière du cinéma
et de l'audiovisuel grâce au talent des
professionnels des cinéastes et grâce à
l'engagement des pouvoirs publics depuis
plusieurs années notamment pendant la
crise sanitaire et après j'étais la
semaine dernière encore à Cannes pour
annoncer 350 millions d'euros un nouveau
plan via France 2030 pour financer le
développement de nos infrastructures de
tournage pour pouvoir doubler nos
capacités de studio tournage à horizon
2030 et aussi doubler nos capacités de
formation ce qu'un des enjeux principaux
c'est bien celui de la relève de pouvoir
former de nouveaux talents de soutenir
des organismes de formation pour se
déployer plus largement et pouvoir
soutenir plus la formation de nouveaux
talents créatifs et techniques ça c'est
un engagement très fort de 350 millions
d'euros d'argent public dans le cadre de
France 2030 pour soutenir cette
industrie je rappelle aussi l'importance
de la régulation et d'avoir amené les
plateformes américaines qui sont
aujourd'hui nos partenaires Netflix
Amazon Disney à investir dans le
financement de la création c'est des
obligations à hauteur de 20% que la
France a mis quand par exemple en
Espagne c'est trois et demi pour cent un
gouvernement de gauche pourtant donc
vous voyez bien qu'on fait le maximum
pour défendre cette exception culturelle
et ce modèle de soutien qui a un modèle
qui permet la diversité qui permet la
diversité des films à aucun moment il
n'est décidé en amont de soutenir un
film pour telle ou telle raison de
rentabilité les films sont soutenus
avant même qu'on sache s'ils vont avoir
du succès ou pas c'est bien les
conditions de la diversité qui sont
mises en place je vous remercie je vous
remercie madame la ministre la parole
est à Monsieur Patrick Hetzel pour le
groupe les républicains
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur le
Ministre chargé des comptes publics
monsieur le ministre la Cour des comptes
estime la fraude sociale entre 6 et 8
milliards d'euros par an et considèrent
que la France la France ne lutte pas
assez contre ce fléau vous venez de
faire des annonces concernant un plan de
lutte contre les fraudes sociales ce
matin permettez-moi de m'étonner de vos
annonces plus de 30 mois après le rendu
du rapport de la commission d'enquête
sur le sujet ici à l'Assemblée nationale
si vous reprenez quelques propositions
formulées dans le rapport de cette
commission je constate toutefois
quelques angles morts importants ainsi
vous ne parlez nullement de l'ordonnance
dématérialisée mesure qui a déjà permis
en Espagne d'économiser plus d'un
milliard d'euros concernant les cartes
vitales vous annoncez 2,3 milliards de
cartes désactivées depuis 5 ans pardon
2,3 millions évidemment de cartes
désactivée depuis 5 ans c'est donc bien
qu'il y avait un problème avec les
cartes vitales il avait toujours été nié
par le gouvernement jusqu'à lors 58
millions de cartes sont actives en ce
moment même mai 2023 selon la Cour des
comptes pour 55,4 millions de porteurs
au maximum selon l'Insee il y a donc
encore du travail monsieur le ministre
par ailleurs vous voulez fusionner la
carte vitale et la carte d'identité
dommage qu'au passage cela revient à
abandonner la carte Vitale biométrique
ce qui est très embêtant c'est que vous
êtes sur un effet d'annonce en effet le
ministère de l'Intérieur qui s'occupe
des cartes nationales d'identité indique
qu'il n'a jamais été consulté par vos
services ma question est donc simple
comment allez-vous faire pour que ce
chantier soit réalisé avant la fin de ce
quinquennat car nos comptes sociaux ne
peuvent plus continuer pendant encore
des années apprendre en charge 75
millions d'assurés sociaux pour 68
millions d'habitants je vous remercie
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Gabriel Attal ministre délégué
chargé des comptes publics merci madame
la Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le députés Patrick
Hetzel je vous remercie pour votre
intervention et votre question vous
connaissez effectivement très bien ces
sujets de fraude sociale vous avez
travaillé depuis plusieurs années sur
ces sujets là j'ai présenté
effectivement ce matin un plan complet
sur le sujet qui s'attaque à la fraude
au cotisations sociales à la fraude aux
prestation maladie à la fraude aux
allocations sociales sur les prestations
maladie effectivement il y a une mesure
importante qui est de travailler à la
fusion entre la carte d'identité et la
carte Vitale sur ce sujet là beaucoup de
choses ont été dites ont été écrites et
pour faire la lumière sur tout cela nous
avons missionné l'Inspection générale
des affaires sociales et l'inspection
générale des finances qui nous ont remis
un rapport que je publie ce matin qui
est que je tiens évidemment à votre
disposition que dit ce rapport il
confirme ce que nous disons c'est à dire
que depuis l'élection d'Emmanuel Macron
en 2017 nous avons procédé à la
désactivation de 2 millions 300 000
cartes vitales en sombre c'était
essentiellement des cartes en surnombre
liés à des doublons d'assurer qui
auparavant étaient par exemple au RSI le
régime social des indépendants et qui
ont rejoint l'assurance le régime
général de l'assurance maladie mais il
n'y a plus de sujets de carte vitale sur
numero dans notre pays c'est le rapport
qui le dit c'est transparent avec les
chiffres qui sont donnés il en reste 942
pour être très précis nous allons
effectivement tout faire pour les
désactiver ensuite le rapport écarte la
mise en place de la carte Vitale
biométrique pour trois raisons un ça
coûte très cher 250 millions d'euros par
an mais si on considère que c'est un
investissement évidemment on peut
regarder deux enjeux de
constitutionnalité en raison des fuites
de données et trois enjeux pratiques les
professionnels de santé disent qu'ils
n'en veulent pas qu'ils ont autre chose
à faire que retenir les empreintes
digitales des patients et par ailleurs
quand vous êtes malade que vous êtes
cloué au lit que vous envoyez votre
femme ou votre mari cherchez vos
médicaments à la pharmacie c'est
compliqué de fournir à votre mari et
votre femme votre main on vous doit pour
aller donner vos empreintes digitales à
votre place donc effectivement la piste
de la fusion entre la carte vitale et la
carte d'identité est recommandée par la
Mission IgA IGF il n'y a chacun des
accords sur le sujet dans le
gouvernement nous avons communiqué ce
matin avec Gérald Darmanin pour annoncer
et François Braun pour annoncer que nous
lançons une mission préfiguration pour
proposer des scénarios en ce sens je
vous remercie allez-y mon cher collègue
merci beaucoup à un président monsieur
le ministre je note bien mais encore une
fois ce que ce que vous proposez on voit
que ça va poser un certain nombre de
problèmes dans l'occasion d'y revenir il
y a un autre angle mort qui est assez
inquiétant c'est qu'à aucun moment vous
ne mentionnez la là aussi les fraudes en
bande organisée c'est devenu un vrai
problème vous devriez vous y attaquer
également merci beaucoup
la parole est à Monsieur François
Jolivet pour le groupement
public vous avez présenté hier votre
plan de lutte contre la fraude sociale
les annonces faites s'inscrivent dans un
plan gouvernemental bien plus large de
lutte contre les fraudes fiscales
sociales et douanières qui fait suite un
travail transpartisan mené sous votre
rigide auquel je suis l'honneur de
participer sans aucun doute le combat
que vous menez deviendra à mon sens une
grande cause nationale entre 15 fait
marqueur de ce quinquennat je veux tout
d'abord au nom du groupe horizon et à
parenté mais féliciter de la mise à
l'agenda de ce plan gouvernemental de
lutte contre les fraudes elle grève le
contrat social et nourrice un sentiment
d'injustice et d'impunité chez nos
concitoyens qui respectent les règles
scrupuleusement il n'y a pas de petite
fraude qui serait plus acceptable que
d'autres il n'y a que la fraude to
fraudeur doit être démasqué sanctionné
et le cas échéant condamné
plusieurs annonces fortes ont été
dévoyées hier comme l'obligation de
résider 9 mois en France pour toucher
les prestations sociales un meilleur
contrôle des pensions de retraite versée
à l'étranger ou la fusion vous venez
d'en parler de la carte vitale et de la
carte d'identité d'autres annonces je le
sais doivent être faites prochainement
car la lutte contre la fraude devient
malheureusement un sport national pour
certains et nous nous souhaitons
horizons et à parenté que cela devienne
une cause nationale ces mesures
s'ajoutent à celles annoncées il y a
quelques semaines pour la lutte contre
la fraude fiscale avec la création d'un
service de renseignement spécifique de
nouvelles sanctions envisagées
l'augmentation des personnels dédiées
notre assemblée examinera d'ailleurs
dans quelques jours le projet de loi
visant à donner aux douanes de nouveaux
moyens et je crois savoir que le Sénat
vient de l'adopter toutes ces annonces
vont dans le bon sens si on voit un
message clair au fraudeur la tolérance
zéro il assurance que l'État ne lui
laissera pas tranquille toutefois
monsieur le ministre l'ambition vous
l'avez la volonté vous l'avez vous ne
voulez passer aux actes et pas que dire
le soutien de la première ministre je
sais que vous l'avez alors quel est
votre calendrier parce que nous avons
tellement entendu parler de choses qui
devaient se mettre en place sans que ça
ne se fasse je vous c'est la parole est
à Monsieur Gabriel Attal ministre chargé
des comptes publics merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député François
Jolivet la question de la lutte contre
la fraude elle est absolument
fondamentale et vous le savez vous avez
participé longuement aux travaux du
groupe de travail transportant que j'ai
mis en place pendant plusieurs mois pour
construire ce plan elle est fondamental
pour des raisons de deniers publics de
finances publiques elle est aussi
fondamentale pour des raisons de
cohésion nationale et singulièrement
quand on parle de la fraude sociale nous
voulons que les Français puissent
continuer à avoir confiance dans notre
modèle social et garder le contrôle sur
notre modèle social c'est reprendre le
contrôle sur ce qui est donné et à qui
c'est donner et c'est le sens du plan
que j'ai présenté j'étais ce matin avec
plusieurs d'entre vous à la Caisse
nationale d'allocations familiale nous
avons échangé avec les agents du service
national de lutte contre les fraudes en
jeu qui nous ont présenté encore
récemment un dossier dans le
Val-de-Marne 8 millions d'euros indument
perçus via un réseau de fraude mafieux
organisé depuis étrangers en
l'occurrence la Roumanie pour 437
dossiers voilà ce à quoi nous avons en
face de nous et ce que ce contre quoi
nous devons lutter ça nécessite des
moyens et c'est la raison pour laquelle
dans le plan que j'ai annoncé il y a des
moyens absolument inédits nous allons
dans les 5 années qui viennent et ça
commencera dès l'année prochaine
augmenter de 1000 effectifs les
effectifs de la lutte contre la fraude
sociale dans les caisses de sécurité
sociale c'est 20% de plus nous allons
investir un milliard d'euros dans de
nouveaux systèmes d'information pour
être plus efficace notamment dans le
croisement de données sur le calendrier
un certain nombre de mesures
s'appliqueront très vite dès le premier
juillet prochain fin du versement
d'allocation sociale sur des comptes
bancaires étrangers hors Union
Européenne premier janvier prochain
durcissement des conditions de résidence
pour bénéficier des allocations sociales
sur notre sol à 9 mois et Fred gestion
supplémentaire pour les fraudeurs à
hauteur de 10%, il y a beaucoup d'autres
mesures on aura l'occasion d'y revenir
notamment dans des auditions c'est
vraiment un travail global du
gouvernement je suis en charge de la
lutte contre la fraude en tant que
ministre des comptes publics mais je
travaille avec mes collègues notamment
évidemment Jean-Christophe combe
s'agissant des allocations sociales et
du modèle social et je sais pouvoir
compter très largement sur beaucoup de
parlementaires de cette hémicycle pour
avancer dans cette voie je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre
la parole est un Monsieur Emmanuel taché
de la Pagerie pour le compressement
national
madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
ma question s'adresse à Monsieur
Christophe Béchu ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires
243 jours de sécheresse par an à
l'horizon 2050 cette prévision
vraisemblable est terrifiante
concernerait et condamnerait
possiblement à court terme l'ensemble du
sud de la France d'après diverses
enquêtes concordantes à titre d'exemple
si cette échéance avait la ville d'Arles
deviendrait dans cette perfective la
ville la plus aride de France à cela
s'ajoute une hausse potentielle de 4
degrés de la température moyenne d'ici
2100 vous comprendrez l'urgence qui
convoque l'État à une prise de
conscience rapide concernant cet enjeu
vital soulevant la question de
l'agriculture de l'agroalimentaire de la
santé de l'urbanisme des transports des
écoles du nucléaire et plus amplement du
champ social si le président de la
République a présenté le 30 mars dernier
le plan o qu'en est-il de ses ambitions
concrète loin des faits d'annonces qui
ne survivront pas à l'épreuve du temps
le génie français a toujours été
mobilisé pour irriguer notre pays des
Gallo-Romains aux grandes
infrastructures de Paul Riquet jusqu'au
travaux d'envergure de la prière le
dérèglement climatique ne peut avoir
raison de siècles d'ingénierie et
condamné des territoires entiers à la
sécheresse dont celui que je représente
pourquoi ne pas faire Darles et de son
territoire une incarnation de ce plan et
un modèle de coopération dans la gestion
de l'eau s'inscrivant dans le même
esprit constructif que la mission
d'inspection interministérielle menée en
Camargue et de gens et dont j'ai été
parti prenante monsieur le ministre
êtes-vous prêt à prendre les mesures
historiques et nécessaires afin de
préserver le Pays d'Arles et plus
amplement tous nos sud de l'aridité
imminente qui les menace je vous
remercie
merci beaucoup la parole est à Monsieur
Christophe Béchu ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires
[Musique]
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
tâché de la page d'abord merci pour
votre question parce que dans votre
question vous insistez sur la réalité du
dérèglement climatique sur la justesse
de la stratégie du gouvernement qui
consiste à dire que il nous faut nous
préparer à 4 degrés et ça tranche avec
certains commentaires qui nous est
arrivé d'entendre de ce côté-là de
l'hémicycle pour remettre en cause
l'intensité de l'atténuation des
politiques que nous conduisons ou le
sens de la planification porté par la
première ministre d'abord vous l'avez
dit l'enjeu pour nous du plan rôle du 30
mars c'est pas les effets d'annonce
c'est de manière concrète ce qui se fait
c'est près de 500 chantiers qui ont déjà
été lancé depuis l'été dernier de
sécurisation et à Arles de manière
générale il y a à la fois le soutien de
l'État il y a ce qui se passe là-bas 1
un plan de 9 millions d'euros pour
restaurer le canal de la haute-croix
avec l'appui de l'état du département de
la région je veux saluer les élus locaux
Arles et le maire Patrick de Carolis 5
millions d'euros par an dans un
dispositif de lutte contre les fuites le
recrutement même d'un agent tracker pour
aller vérifier en amont là où les choses
se passent et je pourrais
prolongée et poursuivre Arles et régions
pilotes au titre et pardon evil pilote à
l'intérieur de la région de manière plus
globale et puis on a un enjeu un jeu
plus vaste qui est une étude plus large
conduite dans le cadre de l'étang d'air
quel est le lien c'est qu'on a un
problème de pollution de l'étang de
Berre à l'eau douce avec le circuit
hydroélectrique et que une partie de cet
excédent d'eau douce c'est la
recommandation notamment du député
d'arriville et du président Voulzy au
lieu de se demander comment on la
rapproche de la mer on pourrait se
demander si cet excédent Dedou son ne
pourrait pas le ramener vers le croc
c'est évidemment quelque chose autrement
plus ambitieux mais qui ne permettrait
de régler deux problèmes en un d'amener
de l'eau douce sur une partie de ce
territoire et d'éviter de nous retrouver
avec une pollution aujourd'hui qui
menace l'écosystème de l'étendue d'air
je suis à la disposition de Patrick de
Caroli de l'ensemble des élus du Pays
d'Arles pour continuer à avancer sur
cette question puisque notre sujet sont
pas les annonces c'est vraiment le fait
de protéger de manière concrète nos
concitoyens
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
mon cher collègue
oui je vous remercie monsieur ministre
vous aurez bien compris qu'effectivement
c'était vous l'avez soulevé cette
question dépasse les clivages politiques
et de souffre pas d'ailleurs qu'on les
relève ou qu'on les soulève
effectivement sur la Crau il y a un vrai
travail à faire concernant l'eau il est
nécessaire merci beaucoup
la parole est à Monsieur Robin Reda pour
le comprenez sans
merci madame la Présidente la question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
jelinistre l'état d'urgence de la santé
mentale à l'école et déclarée dans nos
écoles trop de nos enfants vont mal
c'est le constat des enseignants des
parents partager avec les professionnels
de la santé scolaire quand ils peuvent
intervenir dans les écoles la santé
scolaire qui est née essentiellement
après la Seconde Guerre mondiale elle
avait permis de réparer une jeunesse
meurtrie dans son âme elle avait fait de
l'école le sanctuaire de l'apaisement et
de l'épanouissement plus près de nous la
pandémie à lourdement affectée notre
jeunesse les angoisses climatiques
géopolitiques économiques hypothèque son
avenir de nos jours il y a une certaine
forme de déshumanisation qui s'incarne
dans les violences dans la famille à
l'école et bien sûr le harcèlement
scolaire alors nous devons dans ce monde
violent et dans ce monde de toutes les
angoisses faire du défi de la santé
mentale de nos jeunes une priorité
les dépressions les tentatives de
suicide n'ont jamais été aussi
nombreuses et ce dès le plus jeune âge
pour repérer pour orienter les jeunes il
faut construire une mission collective
dans nos établissements scolaires la
mission des professionnels de la santé
scolaire bien sûr les médecins scolaires
les infirmières les psychologues les
assistants sociaux dont il faut
décloisonner les missions et mieux faire
intervenir ensemble dans les
établissements scolaires mais aussi tous
les adultes de l'école les enseignants
les CPE les assistants d'éducation qui
ont tous un rôle à jouer dans la
vigilance du quotidien l'école bien sûr
ça n'est pas un cabinet médical ça n'est
pas un hôpital mais c'est le lieu idéal
de la prévention pour s'y sentir bien
pour y apprendre les savoirs
fondamentaux il faut y aller avec un
esprit sain dans un corps sain monsieur
le ministre comment pouvons-nous
conjuguer nos efforts pour faire en
sorte que la médecine scolaire puisse à
nouveau servir le bien-être et la
réussite de nos élèves à l'école je vous
remercie
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Papen Diagne ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Robin Reda le rapport très fouillé que
vous avez remis à la Commission des
finances le 11 mai dernier précise et
montre bien à quel point la santé
scolaire était essentielle dans la
détection et la prise en charge des
souffrances psychiques et mentales de
nos élèves les drames récents d'ailleurs
qui ont pu toucher nos élèves le montre
bien permettez-moi
d'adresser mes pensées les plus sincères
et les plus émus à la famille de l'Insee
c'est pour prévenir ces situations
dramatiques avec le ministre de la Santé
François Braun nous prenons un premier
train de mesure
concernant la santé mentale des élèves
premièrement dès la rentrée les
personnels de vie scolaire notamment les
CPE seront formés au secourisme en santé
mentale afin qu'il puisse disposer des
outils nécessaires pour détecter les
troubles les difficultés des élèves ils
sont souvent les mieux placés pour
observer les changements dans le
comportement des élèves les retards les
absences les conflits entre l'élève
deuxièmement dans chaque établissement
une équipe santé mentale sera chargé
d'établir un protocole pour formaliser
une procédure d'action allant de
l'inquiétude à la prise en charge des
élèves en souffrance nous voulons aussi
généraliser un dispositif que le
ministre de la Santé a mis en place
celui de mon parcours psy qui propose
aux jeunes et aux autres huit séances
gratuites chez un psychologue agréé et
enfin nous allons systématiser
l'inscription du numéro national de
prévention du suicide le 31 14 dans les
carnets de correspondance des élèves ce
sera fait à la rentrée le 31 14 c'est
une plateforme avec des professionnels
très bien formés
ce sujet de la santé mentale c'est
évidemment un sujet qui nous préoccupe
tous et je sais que nous pouvons compter
sur votre mobilisation à vous monsieur
le député mais aussi celle de toutes et
tous
la parole est à Monsieur Frédéric
Mathieu pour le groupe la France
insoumise
merci madame la présidente madame la
présidente mesdames et messieurs les
ministres comme le maire de Bruz de la
commune de Bruges j'ai appris dans la
presse la mise en place sur cette
commune de ma circonscription d'un sas
dans lequel vous comptez placer par
roulement de trois semaines des
sans-abris d'Île-de-France pour les
cacher aux yeux des touristes attendus
pour les JO en 2024 des logements en
algeco donc sur un terrain de friche
industrielle pollué aux hydrocarbures et
métaux lourds rien de fixé sur
l'accompagnement social une prise en
charge humaine mise à la trappe d'un
discours vaseux le peu d'éléments
certains inquiète à juste raison
on nous dit que les premières arrivées
devraient intervenir courant ou
peut-être en septembre on ne sait pas
trop tout comme le maire de Bruz je suis
absolument consterné par la maturisme de
l'opération qui cache mal une totale
indifférence à l'égard de la dignité
humaine
la dignité humaine d'ailleurs en guise
de prélu dans la matière le préfet c'est
d'ailleurs illustré récemment il y a
quelques jours en expulsant une famille
d'un hébergement d'urgence dans une
autre commune où elle était hébergée
dans une commune du département avec à
la clé la déscolarisation d'une enfant
de 14 ans tout ça pourquoi bah pour
laisser la place à une autre famille
tout autant en détresse donc ma question
est la suivante faute d'avoir des
explications claires de la part du
préfet auriez-vous la bonté de ne vous
expliquer votre méthode si toutefois il
y en a une je vous remercie
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier Klein ministre délégué
chargé de la ville et du logement
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Frédéric Mathieu merci de votre question
qui va me permettre de rétablir quelques
vérités d'abord la première c'est que le
maire de Bruz a été prévenu il y a plus
de 3 semaines de cette organisation par
Monsieur le Préfet vous pouvez dire non
monsieur mais c'est la réalité telle
qu'elle a été vue avec le préfet ensuite
il est indigne de penser qu'on puisse
mettre en place des sites
d'accompagnement des personnes sans abri
pour les Jeux Olympiques bien évidemment
ces opérations d'accompagnement vers des
sites de d'hébergement temporaire sont
mises en place en accord avec les
associations de solidarité depuis
plusieurs mois et si vous connaissiez
mieux la situation des sans-abris si
vous travaillez comme moi
quotidiennement avec ces associations
vous seriez que les opérations dites de
desserment est un souhait des
associations de solidarité parce que
comment peut-on penser bien accueillir
les les personnes en situation de grande
précarité dans un nombre aussi grand que
tel qu'il soit aujourd'hui
de France plus de 100 000 hébergés sont
aujourd'hui en Île-de-France sur les 200
000 que nous hébergeons chaque soir et
je le rappelle chiffre jamais atteint
depuis 2017 donc oui il est important de
mieux accompagner et c'est le sens de
cette accompagnement en province les
plus fragiles en mettant en place sur
place un accompagnement social et
administratif de ces familles aucun
déplacement des faits sans l'accord des
500 abri bien évidemment un flyer
l'aurait remis et chacun fait le choix
d'aller ou pas en fromage je vous
remercie
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
monsieur Mathieu oui monsieur le
ministre merci pour ces non précision on
reste toujours dans le flou alors le
maire de Bruz je l'ai encore eu au
téléphone pas plus tard que ce midi et
non il n'a pas été prévenu il y a trois
semaines par contre le secrétaire
général adjoint de la préfecture a
raconté qu'il y avait de nombreux
articles de journaux maintenant les
préfets préviennent les maires par voie
de presse c'est intéressant en terme de
dialogue et en fait non il y a eu qu'un
seul article de presse vite fait et qui
n'a jamais cité brut quoi qu'il en soit
le souci du maire et des élus de Bru et
mon souci aussi en tant que député c'est
que ces personnes soient accueillies de
manière digne et vous vous ne connaissez
pas la situation parce qu'on est deux
Français saturés mais en Bretagne aussi
alors mettez des moyens pour que les
gens soient accueillis dignement et
arrêter de croire que il n'y a que
l'Île-de-France qui soit saturé en terme
de centre d'hébergement même les
associations le disent la la
monsieur le ministre
monsieur le député l'intérêt de toutes
les personnes fragiles c'est d'être
cueillis dignement oui la Bretagne est
dans une situation plutôt digne
d'accueil des sans-abris puisque c'est
un des sites un des départements de
France où il y a le moins
Ille-et-Vilaine où il y a le moins de
100 abris aujourd'hui oui vous avez
raison oui vous avez raison
l'accompagnement doit se faire dans de
bonnes conditions oui les élus doivent
être associés et ils le seront et s'ils
n'ont pas été assez ils le seront encore
mieux dans les mois qui viennent bien
évidemment et le dessert en continuera
parce que c'est l'intérêt des plus
fragiles merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre
la parole est à Madame Valéry rabot pour
le groupe socialiste madame la
présidente madame la Première ministre
le 19 mai l'Iran a pendu trois jeunes
Magic casimi salé mirachemy essaie
diaboubi coupable d'avoir pris par au
mouvement femme vie liberté le 25 mai
l'Iran et exécuté en place publique un
homme
s'exécutions s'ajoutent aux deux sens
déjà ordonnés depuis le début de l'année
madame la première ministre le 19 Mai
l'Union européenne a réagi le 19 mai
l'ONU a réagi le 23 mai l'Allemagne a
réagit le 23 mai également 108 chefs de
gouvernement anciens chef de
gouvernement et président ont réagi en
appelant les autorités iraniennes à
rendre compte de leurs crimes depuis le
19 mai la France n'a rien dit Madame la
première midi pourquoi votre
gouvernement s'est-il tue le 10 mai
dernier le président du Conseil des
droits de l'homme de l'ONU a désigné
l'Iran pour présider le prochain Forum
Social 2023 du Conseil des droits de
l'homme des Nations Unies madame la
Première ministre c'est un outrage aux
victimes aux morts et aux prisonniers de
la liberté aussi je vous demande une
chose faire entendre la voix de la
France pour annuler cette nomination
je vous remercie ma chère collègues la
parole est à Monsieur Olivier Belge Tom
ministre délégué chargé du Commerce
extérieur de l'attractivité des Français
de l'étranger
merci beaucoup mesdames la présidente
madame la députée Valérie rabot oui face
à la répression brutale du régime notre
action l'action de la France avisé deux
exigences d'abord soutenir les
aspirations légitimes des iraniennes et
des Iraniens et deuxièmement assurer
qu'il n'y ait pas d'impunité pour les
auteurs de la répression un moment fort
a été la remise du Prix franco-allemande
des droits de l'homme à Massa Amini à
titre posthume et à toutes les femmes
engagées dans ce combat cette pulsion de
vie que la mort de Massa Amini a fait
éclore depuis le mois d'octobre 2022
nous avons aussi adopté 8 trains 8
trains de sanctions européennes dont le
dernier ce lundi 22 mai ceci en
spécifiquement visé les responsables de
la répression judiciaire des
manifestants et plusieurs personnalités
responsables de la propagation d'un
discours de haine appelant à la violence
contre les manifestants à la répression
des droits des femmes iraniennes et à la
dénonciation d'un soi-disant complot
occidental qui serait responsable du
mouvement de manifestation en Iran nous
avons exclu l'Iran de la commission des
Nations Unies qui a sur la condition de
la femme est en fin à une situation
grotesque nous avons établi une mission
d'établissement des faits qui
documentera la répression c'est un pas
fondamental contre l'impunité enfin
l'Union européenne a adopté un nouveau
cadre d'action en s'agissant de l'Iran
via des conclusions du Conseil large et
précise nous utiliserons pleinement ce
cadre d'action et comme vous pouvez le
voir la France et le gouvernement sont à
l'action pour sanctionner les
comportements en Iran merci merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre madame
rabot
monsieur ministre vous avez répondu à
aucune de mes deux questions
et quand on est la France on a une voix
particulière parce que nous sommes les
pays des droits de l'homme nous avons
été les premiers à initier les droits de
l'homme la voie de la France elle
résonne et vous la faites taire vous la
faites taire vous n'avez pas pris la
parole depuis le 19 mai nous ne pouvons
être des héritiers passifs des lumières
des héritiers passifs des
révolutionnaires et c'est ce que vous
êtes aujourd'hui quand on veut
représenter la France quand on préside
la diplomatie française on ne peut pas
être un petit ministre on doit être un
grand ministre des Affaires étrangères
c'est la voix de la France qui doit
s'exprimer pour les droits de l'homme
les droits des femmes la liberté
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
madame la députée qui a la France pays
des droits de l'homme est à l'action aux
côtés de l'Union européenne pour
sanctionner les violations des droits de
l'homme en Iran je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Madame Carolina Badi
pour le comprenez ça ensemble merci
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre
3541 personnes sont décédées sur les
routes de France en 2022 au bilan 2023
nous compterons les trois policiers dont
le véhicule a été percuté à Roubaix la
semaine dernière il y a quelques jours
vous annonciez une série de nouvelles
mesures pour protéger nos concitoyens
sur nos routes cette majorité sera
derrière vous pour soutenir ce plan de
renforcement de la prévention routière
comme nous l'avons toujours été depuis
2017 pour soutenir les mesures qui
sauvent des vies même quand elles sont
impopulaires
avec la vitesse l'autre grand facteur
d'accidentologie c'est la drogue
des études sur simulateur démontrent les
effets du cannabis sur la conduite prise
de risque augmentée tant de réactions
augmenter mauvaise évaluation des
distances ligne droite et vitesse
constante difficile à tenir
23% des accidents mortels implique un
conducteur positif au stupéfiant parmi
eux 80% au cannabis ce n'est
malheureusement pas nouveau mais
certaines affaires médiatisées jettent
un projecteur légitime sur ses accèsdits
sur ses accidents que nous devons éviter
nous le devons alors famille nous ne
devons aux victimes et j'en profite ici
pour souhaiter un prompt rétablissement
au commandant de police nationale fauché
mercredi dernier lors d'un contrôle
routier à Vienne dans ma circonscription
et justement vous avez annoncé
l'ambition de passer de 800 000
contrôles par an à un million c'est
considérable nous pourrions aussi penser
renforcer les peines en cas d'homicide
car il reste il faut être intraitable
avec ceux qui ont tué au volant de leur
voiture alors qu'ils étaient sous
l'emprise de drogue et en même temps
penser prévention il faut restreindre
leurs droits à conduire aux 10% de
consommateurs de cannabis alors comment
sur cette question très
interministérielle permis de conduire
répression prévention traitement des
addictions le Gouvernement entend-il
mener une action résolue pour que ce
fléau cesse d'abîmer les corps et les
familles fauchées de plein fouet je vous
remercie je vous remercie la parole est
à Monsieur Olivier Véran ministre
délégué chargé du renouveau démocratique
et porte-parole du gouvernement merci
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Caroline Abadie
beaucoup d'entre nous avons déjà entendu
cette phrase plus ou moins tard dans la
soirée c'est bon je gère je vais y
arriver la route est pas longue je
connais la route t'inquiète pas j'ai pas
bu depuis deux heures
pardon madame
faites semblant de pas avoir dit ce que
vous avez dit très bien ça veut dire que
vous le regrettez c'est déjà ça
s'il vous plaît
qui prennent le volant et beaucoup
d'ailleurs considèrent qu'ils le prenne
en toute légitimité considérant que leur
état est compatible avec une conduite
sur et dans un certain nombre de
situations ça se termine par un accident
qui peut être mortel pour le conducteur
pour les passagers de la voiture pour
des piétons pour des cyclistes pour
d'autres passagers d'autres voitures et
la question qui se pose au fond dans une
société comme la nôtre c'est à quel
moment est-ce qu'on doit commencer à
considérer que dès lors qu'on a reçu
l'information et qu'on sait qu'on se met
en situation de risque et qu'on met
l'autre en situation de risque est-ce
qu'il ne faut pas revoir les peines
encourus au cas où hélas le risque se
concrétise en drame c'est une réflexion
qui est ouverte la première ministre a
annoncé qu'il y aurait un comité
interministériel au mois de juillet qui
devrait aborder la possibilité de créer
un nouveau délit d'homicide routier un
espèce d'intermédiaire entre l'homicide
[Applaudissements]
la séance est suspendue